Yes, sir.
Yeah, I'll get that paperwork to you right away today, sir.
Yep, on your desk.
By 5.50 today, alright?
Yes, sir.
Hello?
Whoa!
Why does this keep happening?
Stop!
Yes, sir.
Yes.
Who was I talking to?
I'm working on finishing that right now.
Don't worry about it.
Yes, I'm gonna finish it right now.
What do you mean?
What do you mean that I was supposed to have it be double-spaced?
Everything?
Okay, I'll redo it.
Yes, sir.
Oh, you wanted this in this font?
Okay, I'll redo the whole presentation.
Yes, sir.
Hello?
Yes, thank you for calling.
How can I help you?
How may I direct your call?
Oh, you wanna talk to Mr. Mancini?
He's not in the office right now.
Do you want this call?
No.
He's busy.
He's in a meeting.
I know I just said he wasn't in the office.
He's actually in a meeting.
Yeah, it's probably gonna take all day.
You know, so...
Yup.
Can I take a message?
Hemorrhoid cream ready.
Oh, you want this call?
Okay, let me page you through.
Hello?
Yes.
Yes, how can I help you?
Welcome to the company.
Oh, you have a meeting with Mr. Mancini?
He's quite busy.
I believe.
Are you scheduled today?
No?
Hmm... I don't think I can pen you in.
Hmm...
Okay.
Is this the stream?
Yeah, this is the stream.
Do I have any openings?
Hmm... we're booked, like, basically the rest of the year.
You know?
So...
So, can you stop making me depressed with this roleplay?
Welcome back, Master and Princess!
Hello everybody!
Oh my gosh, David too!
Thank you for the 50 gifted!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Welcome to the Stanley Parable!
Ultra deluxe, baby!
Ultra deluxe.
Um...
Yeah.
Uh...
I'm... Oh my god, just hearing all of this...
Actually, you know, my office never sounded so bustling before.
I never worked in like a huge, big company.
Where like...
There's so many people.
And everybody's like doing some crazy thing, you know?
So busted.
No, I said bustling!
I said bustling.
I'm here for a meeting with a Miss Mint Phantom.
Do you happen to know where she is?
She's not in the office today.
She's on vacation indefinitely.
So, you know...
But I could probably pen you in for next week.
You might just come back and then I'll tell you the same thing next week.
Depressed OLs are my thing.
Do you like seeing me like this?
Do you like seeing...
Does this get you going?
Yes?
Yeah?
Kinda hot.
Okay, we're...
You know what?
We're just gonna...
We're just gonna throw that out there.
Anyway, welcome guys to the Stanley Parable.
Sorry, I'm a little out of it because I just got back from running some errands.
So, I made dinner really, really fast.
And then I ate it really, really fast.
So, in my brain, I'm just like...
Thank you for the spookies!
Oh my god!
They didn't charge us for the truck in the parking lot, so I wanted to set that right.
Wait, what?
I had an absolute blast out there.
Oh my god!
Thanks for going!
But...
This is...
You are playing the Stanley Parable Ultra Deluxe.
I...
Full disclosure, I have played this game before.
But it was some time ago.
And I don't quite remember a lot.
And also, I never got to finish the game.
Because my...
My...
Game crashed!
So, I never truly finished the game.
So...
It will be...
Newish...
Experience, I think.
Blizzard!
Jesus!
Hey, Zeus!
Lizard...
Lizard!
Welcome!
And Jacob, welcome!
And Jacob, thanks for the 10 gifted!
Unironically, yes.
Please, get some help.
If seeing...
If seeing depressed OL is your thing...
Get some help.
It won't crash this time.
Perfect stream incoming.
Yippee!
HR called.
The shredder under the complaint box is jammed.
Could you send custodial to clear it?
The shredder under the complaint box.
No kink shaming, boss.
You're right, you're right.
Sorry.
You're so right.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
But seeing depressed snake is your thing?
No!
I don't like seeing him depressed.
What are you talking about?
Hey, I was told you could validate my parking.
Oh...
We only validate parking on leap years, so...
Better luck...
Better luck next time.
Welcome to membership.
Going to work extra hard next month.
And creating a mint phantom themed piece of wax candle.
Oh, I want that!
It's a leap...
It's a leap year?
You're right!
Sorry, I meant every...
Every...
Sorry, I was thinking of our company parties.
They're done on leap years.
Sorry, what I was thinking was we only do them once a century.
Oh, I see.
So, uh...
And that was like at the beginning of the century.
The turn of the century.
So, uh...
You might want to like come back in a couple years, you know?
And then we'll try and validate it for you.
We got in the broom closet ending.
The broom closet ending is my favorite.
I believe I did before.
But of course we can get things again.
You got those photos printed?
Bocos binted?
You got a hundred page review of Nacho Libre on my desk by EOD?
Raymac, you weren't even there!
You weren't even there!
I don't want to hear it from you.
I did...
I did my report.
You just weren't there to see it.
Anyway, let's begin the game, baby.
No way, the call out?
You're next, RySat.
This is the story of a man named Zane.
Mint.
Stanley worked for a company in a big building where he was employee number 427.
Employee number 427's job was simple.
He sat at his desk in room 427 and he pushed buttons on a keyboard.
Orders came to him through a monitor on his desk, telling him what buttons to push, how long to push them, and in what order.
This is what employee 427 did every day.
Every day of every month of every year.
And although others might have considered it soul-wrenching, Stanley relished every moment of his life.
The music is so funky.
It's like giving me Simpsons a little bit.
I don't know why.
As though he had been made exactly for this job.
And Stanley was happy.
He was happy!
And then one day, something very peculiar happened.
Something that would forever change Stanley.
Something he would never quite forget.
He had been at his desk...
High order!
When he realized that not one single order had arrived on the monitor for him to follow.
Sorry, Ted.
For real, for real.
No one had showed up to give him instructions, call a meeting, or even say hi.
No.
Never in all his years at the company had this happened.
This complete isolation.
Something was very clearly wrong.
Wrong!
Shocked, frozen solid, Stanley found himself unable to move for the longest time.
But as he came to his wits and regained his senses...
Sentience.
He got up from his desk and stepped out of his office.
You can't tell me what to do, mister.
You inspired me to play through all of Metal Gear Solid games.
Let's go!
I'm on three now and loving every second of it.
I'm so glad!
Oh my god.
Thank you for that.
Okay, thank you.
What if I don't want to leave my office?
What if I want to have a...
I hate Monday's coffee.
It's 10 AM.
Early morning.
It was a matter of principle.
He wanted to click it.
Close the door.
But Stanley simply couldn't handle the pressure.
The pressure!
What if he had to make a decision?
What if a crucial outcome fell under his responsibility?
He had never been trained for that.
No.
This couldn't go any way except badly.
The thing to do now, Stanley thought to himself, is to wait.
Is to wait.
Nothing will hurt me.
Yeah.
Nothing will break me.
Oh wait, there's...
Okay, shut up!
Forever.
Shut up!
I'm supposed to be doing the commentary!
Stop!
Oh my god, please!
Okay, shut up.
Oh.
Uh oh.
Oh no!
He no longer had the ability to tell.
But the one thing he knew for sure beyond any doubt...
He won't shut up!
The voices!
...was that if he waited long enough, the answers would come.
Eventually, someday, they would arrive.
Soon, very soon now, this will end.
He will be spoken to.
Oh my god.
He will be told what to do.
You're speaking too much!
Now it's just a little bit closer.
The walls are closing in.
Now it's even closer.
Here it comes.
The end is never the end is never the end is never the end.
No, I was reading this.
The G814 partition corp.
Providing partitions for 56 years.
Wowee.
Who knew that we needed partitions for so long?
The phone makes a strange sound.
Oh.
Why is that to the...
To the picture frame?
What the...
I hear typing sounds everywhere.
No matter what I look at.
Love the new suit.
Thank you!
The narrator is the commentary.
She finally left us to go back to the office.
Make the partition.
Nothing.
My friend!
428 doesn't even give it a window.
They hate him.
All his co-workers were gone.
What could it mean?
Stanley decided to go to the meeting room.
Perhaps he had simply missed a memo.
Yeah, of course.
It's a memorial day!
Duh!
This is the automated cleaner invoice.
Your crimson entrance at WrestleTuber has now been dealt with.
No further actions needed.
Thank you.
No matter how hard Stanley looked, he couldn't find a trace of his co-workers.
Who farted?
Why are there mugs like this?
We have an order.
Oh, wait.
He has already found a case!
S-s-so sorry!
Oh, it's all right.
I have to do it over again.
Of course!
I can't walk!
Just step up!
Step up, you son of a...
No, no, no, no!
That's so bad.
Won't your boss see that?
Rip number one, dad.
Turn off all their computers.
Wait!
Where's that go?
Hmm, okay, thank you.
Thanks for the five gifted speedy fire.
Forgot how sassy.
Shut up!
Why can't I explore?
Vodgang here, thank you!
I cancelled his illegal movie download.
Justice.
This guy escaped.
417 is in the ceiling.
I hate my days.
Okay.
This is the meeting room.
Just kidding.
Oh.
Oh no!
Oh no, it's this!
It's this, it's this, it's this!
Hmm.
Am I a good girl?
Am I a good Stanley or am I bad Stanley?
Hmm.
It's the choice.
Am I a good girl or am I a bad girl?
Bad Stanley.
Oh, my eyes.
Always a good Stanley.
Even if I don't, even if I lose my way?
This was not the correct way to the meeting room.
And Stanley knew it perfectly well.
Perhaps he wanted to stop by the employee lounge first.
Just to admire it.
Of course, of course.
Oh, I see.
I want to go in there.
I want to go back there.
Hmm.
Oh, here we go.
The lounge.
Yes.
Truly a room worth admiring.
Oh, yes.
It had really been worth the detour after all.
Just to spend a few moments here in this immaculate, beautifully constructed room.
Stanley simply stood here, drinking it all in.
Ah.
Smells like, smells like yesterday's perfume.
Really, really worth it being here in the room.
A room so utterly captivating that even though all your co-workers have mysteriously vanished, here you sit looking at these chairs and some paintings.
Really worth it.
It is.
Just love that, like that 10 a.m.
At this point, Stanley's obsession with this room...
I can't get it worded.
...and reflected poorly on his overall personality.
It's possible that this is why everyone left.
Now you're judging my character?
125 for drinks is pretty good.
I don't know.
Stanley sat around waiting for more dialogue.
I think it should be free.
But when a long time had passed and there was no more, he decided that the game was trying to send him a message.
Yeah, look, you got your, you got, this is where I always sit.
They say this is Stan's seat.
That's what it says.
You can't see it, but it's written right there.
There's also, they got the stain out pretty good.
That's, they say that's Stan's seat.
And then this, this is, this is big old Joe's seat.
You know, he's just a, he's like the biggest guy you'll ever meet.
What is this actually?
What is it?
Wait.
What?
What is?
Is?
If?
Duet the plane.
The weeks?
Hi, I'm hungry.
Is that what it says at the bottom?
Time to zoom.
I can't zoom.
Is there a zoom button?
Is there a zoom?
You can look closer.
How do I do that?
Also, if I press right click, I move.
Move forward too.
That's kind of crazy.
See?
Oh, right click makes me walk forward.
Let's check the key binds real quick.
Oh, it's auto walk.
Okay.
There is a jump.
Interesting.
Interact.
Maybe additional.
Okay.
But at last, he'd had enough of the amazing room and took the first open door on his left to get back to business.
Look, I'm auto walking.
I'm auto...
You can't tell the difference, but I am.
Okay.
Let's all guess.
Wait.
What did he say?
Uh-oh.
I didn't hear him.
Okay.
Let's tell...
See if you can tell the difference.
Am I auto walking or am I walking walking?
He wants me to go this way.
Oh, okay.
And so he detoured through the maintenance section, walked straight ahead to the opposite door...
Oh, no!
... and got back on track.
Wait.
What's here?
Beep!
What is this?
But Stanley didn't want to go back to the office.
No!
He wanted to wander about and get even further off track.
So now in order to get back, he needed to go, um...
Uh...
Well...
Do do do do do do!
Do do do do do!
From here it's, um...
Left.
Oh.
That's nice.
This is a fake door.
It doesn't even interact.
Oh, no!
No.
It's to the right.
My mistake.
Oh, narrator!
You don't want to get on my...
No!
No.
No, no.
Not the right.
Why would I have ever said it was to the right?
What was I thinking?
You don't want to get on my bad side!
It's clearly...
Am I stuck here?
Just take me back up.
He's got it.
We're fine.
This way.
Is someone in there?
It's kind of spooky down here though, you guys.
Oh, wait.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, I remember this room.
Fired.
That's not me.
Oopsie.
Oh, sorry.
I'm closing.
I went to the spoiler reversing.
Uh-oh.
Uh...
Mister...
I'm gonna look at the spoilers.
Okay.
We're good, Stanley.
I'm walking... I'm bee-lining it there, Mr. Narrator.
Don't worry about it.
Uh-oh.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
I bugged the game.
No.
I didn't touch it.
No, just let me...
Oh, this is what happens when you're British.
British brain.
Okay, then.
It's an adventure.
Come, Stanley.
Let's find the story.
These look connected.
They are.
These go different ways.
Let's go this way.
Okay, I'm exploring.
Inner guilt.
Everyone knows what you did.
They're just holding back to let you tortured.
This is the worst adventure I've ever been on.
I can promise you there definitely was a story here before.
Are you sure?
Do we need to restart the game again?
No.
I find it unlikely that we'll ever progress by starting over and over again.
I'm in the back room for real, though.
Wait a second.
Oh, come on.
No.
All of his co-workers were gone.
What could it mean?
Stanley decided to go to the meeting room.
I just hate my boss.
Okay, bee-lining, bee-lining, bee-lining.
And there's no doors!
Okay, it's worse.
I might be remembering this wrong.
It's possible the story is back where we just came from.
What are you talking about?
Why don't we go back the other direction and see if we missed anything?
Okay.
In this room.
415.
Never liked that guy.
417.
It's definitely in the walls.
In here, in here, in here.
That looks so important in there.
Okay, never mind.
Um...
In here.
No.
Aha!
I knew we'd miss something.
The story.
Here it comes.
Okay.
No, wait.
Never mind.
Not the story.
Okay, let's head back the other way.
And retrace our steps.
That's what I just did.
Mr. Narrator!
Oh my god, Mr. Narrator's...
Now this...
Well, I'll be honest.
I don't recognize this place at all.
Is this the story?
I don't think so.
I'm back...
I can't quite recall, but I believe my story took place in an office building.
Is that correct?
I'm back on the farm.
Do you remember, Stanley?
I don't know anything.
Since I've completely forgotten what we were supposed to be doing, how about this?
This.
You win!
Congratulations!
I beat the game!
I know you put in a lot of hard work, and it really paid off.
So, good job.
Oh!
Oh no.
I don't feel right about this at all.
Speedrun?
We both know you didn't put in any actual work for that win.
Some people win fair and square.
And this was not one of those situations.
Okay?
I'm getting weirded out by whatever this place is.
I don't care what might happen this time.
I have to restart.
Okay.
Alright, I've got a solution.
And to make sure we don't get lost, I've employed the help of the Stanley Parable Adventure Line.
Just follow the line.
How simple is that?
Okay.
I sure hope nothing happens with this line.
Oh, this way.
This way.
Okay.
This way, this way.
You see?
The line knows where the story is.
It's over in this direction.
Onward, Stanley!
To destiny!
Wouldn't wherever we end up be our destination?
Even if there's no story there?
Or to put it another way, is the story of your destination...
still a story?
Simply by the act of moving forward, are we implying a journey such that a destination is inevitably conjured into being via the very manifestation of the nature of life itself?
via the very manifestation of the nature of life itself?
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
That got a bit weird back there.
Well, I'd like to apologize.
Johnny!
Bravo!
The narrator should make the lead line into something really pretty.
That way it leads the...
Oh my...
Oh!
Go!
Yeah!
Pass through here...
Oh my god, I can't even hear myself think.
Oh!
Around here...
Um...
Consul...
Consul reports!
Employee 432 peer reviews!
Is that me?
Financial records!
Wait...
This way...
This way, right?
Oh,
thank god.
Oh, thank god.
Look at the what?
The fern?
Stanley, this fern will be very important later in the story.
Make sure you study it closely and remember it carefully.
You won't want to miss anything.
Glory to the fern.
I got a certain ghost in my kitchen that was cute af but keeps rummaging my kitchen at night.
I think it's haunted.
What do I do?
It's probably best to appease those sorts of things.
You know?
Wait, what?
We're back at the office?
No, no, no.
You do know we're looking for the Stanley Parable, right?
The story?
Is any of this ringing a bell?
I'm still going.
The line is my destiny.
Oh!
No way!
Cool school!
Thanks for the 10 gifted!
Oh, no, no, no.
Not again.
How could you have done this to us?
What's that one over there?
After everything we've been through, you...
Oh, I can't take this anymore.
Restart.
The line wanted spoilers.
Okay.
You know what, Stanley?
I say forget the adventure line.
What's it ever done for us?
We're intelligent people, right?
Why can't we make up our own story?
Something exciting.
Daring.
Mysterious.
This all sounds perfectly doable.
Why don't we simply start wandering in...
Well, I don't know.
How about this direction?
This direction?
Well, I don't really have a choice now, do I?
This is exciting.
Just me and Stanley forging a new path.
This is really backrooms-esque.
What do you want our story to be?
Go wild.
Use your imagination.
I'm ready for it.
Okay.
All right.
Setting.
Dingy.
Dingy office.
They're about to go out of business.
They're, uh...
Let's see.
What kind of business do they do?
They do the real top business.
They're...
They're really business, business.
But they're just not doing so well because...
Because bigger business has moved in on their turf.
Bigger business has moved in on their turf.
And...
So they're just like...
Man, we're just...
I don't know if we're going to make it.
So the business...
employee is just like...
We can't go out of business.
This is my livelihood.
How will that feed my kids?
And so they're just like...
Well, what do you want to do about it?
And are they a gang?
Stop.
No spoilers.
And so they...
Yeah, Bigger Business Inc.
Business is business.
So...
To get...
To get rid of the other bigger business...
They thought...
Well, maybe we should make a better product.
But no.
It's not good enough.
Bigger business does better business.
Not better business.
They just do bigger, bigger business.
Bigger business is so big that it even covers...
So much of the business.
And so instead...
They have to kill them.
It's time to take down bigger business.
Bigger business...
Has to be eliminated.
And so they start...
They start shipping...
Let's see.
Rats with the black...
Sorry.
I just tried to get some chapstick out.
And it just squirted everywhere.
Rats with what?
The black plague.
Did you guys know...
It's still possible to get the bubonic plague...
Nowadays?
I learned that the hard way.
Anyway.
I don't know where I was going with that.
Oh no.
Not you again.
It's being a mess.
I'd also like to veto the line from having any role in our awesome new story.
No lines or monitor rooms.
Just don't acknowledge it.
Okay.
I'm not going to even...
Look at it.
Guys.
I think I should start a business.
Hmm.
Spooky company.
Always monitoring.
What do we monitor?
You ask?
Every type of business.
We get to make a decision.
From here the story is in our control.
How important we mustn't squander the opportunity.
In fact I believe I need a minute to think here.
Just walk in circles for a minute.
Okay.
So I know that each door has to lead somewhere.
Which means that somewhere...
A big business government?
No.
There must be a reverse door that leads here.
No no no.
Spooky company always monitoring.
And that in turn means that our destination corresponds with that counter inverted reverse door's origin.
So starting from the right, let us ask, will taking the right door lead us to where we're going?
And since the answer is clearly yes, then by all accounts the door on the right is the correct one.
We're already making profit with this business.
Great job, Mint.
Thank you!
Our destiny awaits.
The confusion ending.
You've been playing this confusion ending for...
Hold up, what's this?
Nineteen minutes.
The confusion ending?
First restart.
This is just a...
It's all been scripted to me!
Eight times?
Find a bookstore?
That's really how all this goes?
Wait, what was the other place that we got to?
Nonsense, philosophy and music.
So now according to the schedule, I restart again.
No no no, hold on!
Am I just supposed to forget?
End up in another building?
Find the line?
My mind goes blank simply because it's written here on this... this thing.
Wall.
Okay.
Oh, it's begun to deteriorate?
Why don't I get to decide?
Why don't I get a say in all of this?
Is it really?
I think I had started investing on some spooky company always monitoring stocks.
Thank you!
I don't want to forget what's going on.
I don't want to be trapped like this.
I won't restart the game.
I won't do it.
Can I sit down?
Stopped?
Does that mean... did we do it?
Did we break the cycle?
Whatever it is that made this schedule.
How would we even know?
Will someone come for us?
Will something happen?
This guy loves to hear himself talk.
After a long time, Stanley dies!
Wait there, Raider!
I don't want to die.
I'm already dead.
I'm not ready.
I suppose in some way that this is a kind of story.
Wouldn't you agree?
I'm not quite sure if we're in the destination or the journey.
Though they're always saying that life is about the journey and not the destination.
So I hope that's where we are right now.
In the journey.
We'll find out, won't we?
Eventually.
In the meantime, if you don't...
Okay.
We've restarted the game, everybody.
All of his co-workers were gone.
What could it mean?
I think he's saying...
Stanley decided to go to the meeting room.
Perhaps he had simply missed a memo.
I think he's normal.
Are you normal, Mr. Narrator?
Yes!
When Stanley came to a set of two open doors, he entered the door on his left.
He decided to go to the meeting room.
You can't tell me what to do.
They're like, yeah, you committed.
How do I know if it's his left, my left, you know?
Well, here's the meeting room.
Oh, tips for not getting fired.
Feeling a wave of disbelief, Stanley decided to go out to his boss's office, hoping he might find an answer there.
Not to solve a dispute with a co-worker.
Let it ball up inside you.
Take it out passive-aggressively on other co-workers.
Resent co-workers for not supporting you more.
This feels too real.
Make sure your slide has a slick blue graphic in the header.
Oh yeah.
Sounds legit.
Everyone is unique.
You, most of all.
Which one am I?
Who is me?
I'm Minto.
Stanley walking through the parable leg.
To do.
Synergize core value expenditures.
Gosh.
That is like the best thing to do on a Monday.
Shift global market...
Pa-pa-parade.
The parade.
Oh my gosh.
My company.
We always have a global market parade.
It's big.
It's exciting.
We get blow-up dolls.
I mean.
Wait.
No.
The inflatable ones.
I mean like the...
You know what I'm talking about.
The ones that are floating.
Monetize free-to-play.
Love it.
Monetize everything.
Do everything for profit.
Help.
I'm a post-it.
Inflatable tube guys.
No.
The ones that like...
In like the parades.
Oh the floats.
Yes.
The floats.
We have floats.
Push for funding for...
R&D?
A new coffee machine.
We have enough GMP for this?
Get Chris out of the broom closet.
The bloons closet.
Giant blow-up doll in the sky?
No.
Standardized graphs.
440x wide.
Not cost efficient.
Papers are too synergized.
Fire paper guy.
Oh.
Fire the paper guy.
Oh no.
Hire somebody to fire the paper synergizing guy.
Who moved my desk?
All...
Scratched out.
Employee.
Jim.
Employee Jim.
Tomorrow complete today's unfinished agenda items.
Write next day's agenda.
Reflect.
What else we got here?
Meeting schedule.
Mergers?
We are broke Wednesday.
It's Monday so we're on weekly targets admin.
Marketing Mondays.
Mintara Mondays.
Wait I didn't do anything.
Don't fire me.
Oh.
Paper bag friend.
I don't know what to tell you man.
Synergize is just you know there's a perfect blend of synergize.
Oof.
Who died?
Do not alter without consulting whiteboard manager.
Oh.
By quarterly post review review.
We need less reviews.
402 plus 405 went to get rid of the death sport portion in the primary review schedule.
But I think that's a stupid idea.
More water coolers.
More water cooler heaters.
Charts need to be more hip.
To appeal to teenage demographic.
Find teenagers to put in teenage demographic.
Big net?
Some sort of child trap?
Size of demographic.
Can't read what it says.
Space.
Between the teenagers.
Teenagers.
Throw something in the idea's bin.
No more bins.
Trash cans.
Renaming of the idea bin.
Firing of me.
Oh.
Better safe than profit.
No.
Ignore that everybody.
Profits are everything.
Business club.
Rule one.
References are not all they're cracked up to be.
I didn't know that there was writing behind you.
It's so funny.
Crafts about things and money.
These people.
Oh my gosh.
I think I have a thing or two to learn about this place.
Oh wasn't there somebody locked in here?
The broom closet.
But there was nothing here.
Oh wait I remember this one.
And got back on track.
No.
Just gonna chill in here for a bit.
You know.
Just gonna.
There was nothing here.
No choice to make.
No path to follow.
Just an empty broom closet.
It's not empty though.
Look at this.
He is devaluing your existence.
Broom and closet and bucket.
It was baffling that Stanley was still just sitting in the broom closet.
He wasn't even doing anything.
At least if there was something to interact with he'd be justified in some way.
As it is.
He's literally just standing there doing sweet F.A.
What's F.A.?
Just a broom closet.
Are you really still in the broom closet?
Standing around doing nothing?
Why?
Please offer me some explanation here.
I'm genuinely confused.
Fudge all.
Well you know there's a lot of good things.
There's a lot of good qualities about every room in a building, you know?
Every room should have a purpose.
You don't realize there's no choice or anything in here, right?
That's okay.
I'm just admiring its value.
If I'd said Stanley walked past the broom closet at least you would have had a reason for exploring it to find out.
But it didn't even occur to me because literally this closet is of absolutely no significance to the story whatsoever.
I never would have thought to mention it.
Then why'd you create it?
Why did you give it life?
Why did you give it an existence?
Maybe to you this is somehow its own branch or path.
No!
Maybe when you go talk about this with your friends you'll say, oh did you get the broom closet ending?
Did you get the broom closet ending?
Was my favorite.
I hope your friends find this concerning.
No, I'm admiring it.
What's that?
Stanley was fat and ugly and really really stupid.
He probably only got the job because of a family connection.
That's how stupid he is.
I'm a nipple baby!
That or with drug money.
Also Stanley is addicted to drugs and hookers.
Oh yeah!
Stanley's living the life!
Well I've come to a very definite conclusion about what's going on right now.
You're dead.
You got to this broom closet, explored it a bit, and were just about to leave because there's nothing here when a physical melody of some sort shut down your central nervous system and you collapsed on the keyboard.
Well in a situation like this, the responsible thing is to alert someone nearby so as to ensure that your body is taken care of before it begins to decompose.
Hello anyone who happens to be nearby?
The person at this computer is dead.
I'm dead!
Therefore pray to any number of your countless human physiological vulnerabilities.
It's indicative of the long term sustainability of your species.
Please remove their corpse from the area and instruct another human to take their place, making sure they understand basic first person video game mechanics and filling them in on the history of narrative tropes in video gaming so that the irony and insightful commentary of this game is not lost on them.
Thanks narrator.
When you've done that just step out into the hallway.
What am I supposed to do?
Um...
I am understanding the irony and the um... the intricate commentary of this... of this uh... situation.
Loved your wrestling.
You've ruined my taste buds.
Thanks Viv!
Thanks for a run.
Glad you liked my wrestling.
Ah, second play.
You too?
Unbelievable.
I'm at the mercy of an entire species of invalids.
Perhaps there's a monkey nearby you can hand the controls to.
A fish?
Fungus?
Have you decided to not move on to the afterlife to spend time here?
Thanks Joe!
I'll just be waiting for when you're ready to pick up the story again.
Nah, nah.
Yeah.
I'm an invalid.
Um... I don't know.
It's my destiny to be in the broom closet.
I think I'm pretty valid.
I think I'm pretty valid though.
Look, the light kind of just reminds me of the sun.
Which you're not really supposed to stare at, but you know, when you just look at it it's just like, you know, maybe the sky turned uh...
like an ashy brown and the sun is around.
You can just imagine it.
You can just think of yourself being outside and living a free life.
You know?
You don't have to...
You don't have to stay confined to these walls.
You are so valid.
Thank you!
Joe, look at the bamboo shoot!
You can just look at the sun and you can just ponder.
You can be like I'm just this tiny, insignificant creature in this vast, vast, endless universe.
But in this moment I feel like I'm one with the universe.
Is there anything else to do?
Am I done?
Um...
What's that sound?
God, I'm scared of the outside world.
The broom closet's the best!
Uh...
Hmm...
Ah!
Oh...
No!
Please narrator!
Please, please, please!
I'm on my knees!
I'm begging you, please!
Let me go back to the broom closet!
Please!
No!
What did he say?
What did he tell me?
Sorry, Mr. narrator.
I'm not really paying attention.
Ooh!
This area's so spooky.
Um...
Upstairs!
Oh, upstairs!
Thank you.
Is there actually a broom closet ending though?
Or... Oh, I remember this room, kind of.
It's the bathroom.
...
I've got the feeling.
I've got a feeling.
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
The money is for stealing.
A feeling.
Woo-hoo!
But not your money.
Of course.
Not your money.
Extreme time.
Extreme bathrooms.
...
Say, that's a lovely purse.
Mr. Krabs felt that.
...
Oh my god!
The panda!
...
Business strategy.
Yes, my favorite strategy.
Take out the competition.
...
Which way are we going?
Oh.
Stanley.
...
What did I say?
I can't hear you.
Could you speak up a little louder?
...
How could you say your words enunciate instead of a mumbling?
I don't understand what you're trying to say to me.
...
I don't know the words to the song, but I know that those words will be created in my heart for you, baby girl.
Tra-ta-ta-ta-ta-ta.
Well,
this is the longest elevator in the world.
...
But it's not as long as my love for you.
In this world with nuestro trif... machine.
...
Well that's...
What did he say?
Does this actually end?
I don't know.
Recommendations from the overnight committee.
We're going again in circles around each other And our love is burning bright
But I'm doing here without you But I know that I'll see you tonight
I don't know if I should stop it or not.
We're almost there?
Okay.
It's glowing slow because the weight limit is being reached.
It's just you in the elevator, right?
I shot them.
I shot them with an arrow of love Just like me I'm just so smitten for you, girl
Oh, come on!
I am the most expensive boss.
If I go down...
Thanks for making the elevator go slow, Mr. Narad.
Da da da da da da da da da Da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da Da da da da da da da
da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da What's the equivalent for sticky to for elevators?
Solid cupid and their 5.56 rifle of love.
What a thrill Okay.
Silence and darkness rule the night
I can't remember the lyrics if I'm not singing it.
Hum...hum...hum...business...time...oh...business time.
Our hostile takeover is the new bi-annual percentage.
Two votes!
Snake Eater Bossa Nova Elevator Remix.
The beige pages.
Switch Lilies by Claude Manille.
Corte Blanche featuring...Mont Blanc.
Wow.
No!
Secret pin number.
Hmm.
But of course, Stanley couldn't possibly have known this.
Boob.
Stanley just sat around twiddling his thumbs.
Trying to input anything on the device was useless since he could never possibly know that the combination was 2845.
Surely we'll find it out.
Okay.
There's two...kangaroos here.
Two.
Two, eight, four, five.
Two...um...there's a cat.
Two, uh...three.
Hum...um...um...um.
Oh, there's a globe!
Around the world in 80 days.
Eight.
Oh, god.
But it turns out that the panel's emergency override kicked in.
Oh!
And the door just opened all by itself.
And Stanley got the hell along with the story.
Well, whoop de do.
Whoop-de-do.
Okay.
Dang, hold on.
There.
I can't even... I can't even solve the rest of the puzzle because it's...
It's all black.
It's too dark.
Okay, a little spooky.
I don't like it.
It's a little scary.
I wouldn't trust it!
Oh, God.
Okay.
Loading.
Peculiar.
No, no, no.
Not go unanswered for long.
Whoa!
No, I like being a pawn and a little cog in the machine.
I like not thinking.
I like, you know, just...
Oh!
Mind control facility.
Back up.
Go back up?
Oh, we can.
You're right.
I don't think so.
I don't think I did.
Never mind.
Stanley actually got back into the elevator and went back up.
Silly me.
Yeah, silly you.
Why did Stanley do that when he knew that it would just lead back to his boss's office?
Well, that's a great question.
Spank thinks we're the tickets in.
I just can't wait to find out.
The end is never the end.
There's never the end.
I'm excited to find out, too.
Something must have changed.
Something seemed a little... Hmm, see, these lights are brighter.
Here we are, Stanley.
It's your boss's office.
Yeah!
Exactly the way it was before you got onto the elevator.
That door.
It's still just exactly what it is.
What a decision you've made to come up here and look at the office again.
This has fleshed out the plot of the story in new and fascinating ways I could have never anticipated.
It's that keen eye for storytelling that you have.
An incisive, rapid fire of critical plot points.
One after the other.
Weaving a rich tapestry of uncompromising narrative.
Wow.
I'm bolted to the edge of my seat.
Are you done, mister?
Are you done?
Are you done being a little... a little pissy baby?
Certificate of...
P-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p.
Jesus.
What's this?
Shanti.
2003.
Vintage.
Lucky.
I guess I'll go back down now.
I guess I'll, you know...
Okay, I'll listen to you.
I'll be able to get to the stream in a minute, glad.
I was able to tune into...
On my birthday!
How does he keep coming up with all this?
Happy birthday, Mocha!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday...
Oh no, I'm yawning.
To you.
Happy birthday, dear Mocha.
Happy birthday to you.
Surely this time, Stanley will walk forward into the spooky corridor, won't he?
No.
You know, if you want me to do something, you gotta give me the option to not do anything else.
Did you think we were going to go forward down the spooky corridor?
Noooo.
It's time once again to go back up in the elevator.
How not stupid?
I can't even begin to grapple with what might be up there.
Is it the boss's office again?
Or what if it's the boss's office this time?
The suspense is killing me.
The boss's office!
Boss's office!
Meep!
Thank you!
Boss's office!
Yes!
The boss's office!
Oh my god.
It's the boss's office.
This absolutely changes everything for me.
Give me a time out here for a minute while I process this.
Oh!
This is making me sleepy.
Okay, I'm ready.
I'm prepared to embrace this stunning revelation and to move forward with...
No!
No, wait!
No wait?
No!
I need more time to process.
Oh.
Please hold, everybody.
Please hold.
I'm gonna make this into, like, my Be Right Back screen.
I remember wanting one of those drinking birds when I was a kid.
Everybody hold on.
Just pretend I'm going to the bathroom.
I have fully come to terms with it.
I have made space in my world view for this astonishing new reality.
As before, I turn to your expert eye for gripping narrative, Master Stanley.
Wait, but I'm the maid.
You're the master.
I'm just a maid.
I don't have to do... I don't deserve the title of master.
Master Stanley.
It's got a nice ring to it, though.
Of course.
Going back down again a bit.
Max, like, you would be cute.
I mean, sure, now it's obvious.
But you have to understand that 30 seconds ago, this kind of thing had never been attempted before.
I have to be your maid.
A frame of reference to even anticipate it.
That's just how revelatory Stanley's decision making is.
Yeah.
A breath of fresh air in a landscape of storytelling that has grown stale and repetitive.
Loading, loading, loading.
It's not going to get me this time.
It didn't even talk.
I can see the mind control and...
Oh, there it is.
It's like a little...
They should have done a better job at hiding it.
I feel like, you know.
Should we go up one more time?
I mean...
It's like right there.
Stanley walks straight ahead through the large door that read Mind Control Facility.
You know what?
Every time he tells me what to do, I don't want to do it.
Every time he's just like, Stanley does this.
I'm like, no I don't.
I have free will.
I...
I'm Stanley.
You know what?
What?
I've just thought of something.
Okay.
Hold on, let's stop for a minute.
Oh.
Don't you realize?
It's the anticipation, Stanley.
Watching me while sewing up my off-cut cosplay.
You and I, we have no way of knowing what will be at the top of this elevator.
See you there.
But the suspense.
The suspense?
The agony of waiting and anticipating.
Oh my god, the thrill.
And having to guess.
That's the real thrill.
Oh, I simply don't want to let that feeling go.
It's so precious.
So fleeting.
Why don't we take this elevator ride nice and slow?
Oh my god.
There we go.
Bosses.
Isn't this so much more exciting?
You know, Stanley, it seems like nowadays the only thing that audiences want is to be shocked as loudly and frequently as possible.
Please don't do that.
No, no, no.
Please.
But where's the tension?
Where's the tension?
Where's the trust in the audience to build a slow and nuanced appreciation for the story?
You can go your own pace, Winter.
Why aren't we given time to imagine the surprises?
To have to think and to anticipate and then to marvel at the eventual reveal.
This is storytelling, Stanley.
What you and I are doing right now.
This is the most exciting narrative to be developed in years.
And it's really all because of you.
It's innovative, I know.
I know.
Never.
He wants to marry.
I thought he was kind of scary looking.
Sharp.
You're great at the Canadian truck placement though.
Thank you!
Thanks, Drex!
Thanks for going.
I'm a role model!
Okay.
Oh.
My mid-talk?
Okay.
Stan-talk?
I don't know if you realize the impact you have on them.
This is the kind of gesture that might leave a tremendous impact on them for the better.
The better?
Whoa!
Boss's office!
The room where we're holding the press conference should be just around the corner here somewhere.
Live on stage.
All eyes on Stanley.
Stanley.
World's healthiest human being.
All tricks revealed.
Doctors hate her!
We did it.
The pyramids.
The guy who went to Mars.
Who is that over there?
Look at this though.
Oh, here.
I thought...
I thought for a second that was Jack's films.
Stanley reveals all in his new book.
I'm a published author even?
Okay.
World peace baby!
Ah, yes.
Here it is.
Just through this door.
The Stanley Parable Stanley.
Tonight.
Live on stage.
What was I saying over there?
The man.
The process.
The myth.
The legend.
The world's first sentient machine.
Wow.
Have you guys heard how like...
Like these...
These tech places that are like...
That are like having...
Creating robots.
First of all, I have an issue.
Why do the robots they create have to look so human?
Why can't they like look like cool robots?
You know?
Why can't they look like Drossel from Fireball?
Why can't we get just hot...
I mean cute...
Why can't we just get robots instead of like...
Uncanny Valley humans?
You know what I'm saying?
But also...
Why are they all so flirty?
Why is it all...
The built female robots are just like...
Oh, hey.
You are just...
It is just a wonderful time meeting you tonight.
And I just...
They just say some really unhinged things that make me think.
Like...
If they...
Are they actually trying to...
You know...
Get with a human and then have human robot babies?
I just don't know.
Because we need Chobits.
We will never have Chobits.
You know why?
Because they are not anime.
But you know what I bought recently?
Two!
Thank you!
Hold on.
This sounds terrible.
Can we go back to the hot robots bit?
I don't know what you are talking about.
You know what I bought recently?
I bought...
Have you guys ever heard of the gate box?
It is basically like...
The original is this giant like...
Tubular looking thing.
And it is pretty big.
But inside is a hologram.
Anime lady.
And...
I didn't buy the original one.
Because they are usually...
They are like really expensive.
The gay box?
No, the gate.
The...
The gate box.
What is wrong with you guys?
Did you buy a hot robot?
Maybe.
But...
If you are interested in getting one.
They actually...
First of all, they have a booth.
But second of all, they have a version of it.
That is...
It is like a little...
It is like a figure box almost.
And it is 6000 yen.
It is basically just like...
A glorified Alexa.
But with an anime girl in it.
And they also make one of a...
Oh gosh, what is that anime?
I don't have my phone in...
Where did I leave my phone?
Oh no, I don't know where my phone is.
But...
They have like one of the original girl.
And they have one of...
Of an anime character.
I can't remember her name.
But yeah, they are like affordable.
So...
And...
With the one that I got.
Maybe I shouldn't say this.
It just arrived to my...
Proxy like...
The other day.
So I won't have it until I get back.
But I am going to experiment a little bit with it.
I am going to experiment a little.
Has an anime girl in it.
Are you sure it isn't a gay box for you?
It is the gay...
Box.
Yeah.
Something unrelated.
But do you have Dave the Diver?
I do not.
I actually got the...
The...
The Godzilla.
I got the Godzilla DLC.
But yeah.
So if you always...
If you saw the gay box and always wanted one.
But were just like me and being like this is way too expensive.
I haven't...
I haven't tried it yet.
But I am sure it will be awesome.
Anyway.
No.
Is that my name?
Stanley Ryder?
Okay.
The heart.
Oh.
Go get him.
Almonds.
Chair.
Gum.
Table.
Nut bar.
Oh God.
Hold on.
The dude who came up with pizza.
I can't compete with him.
I can't do it.
Oh God.
I am just going to eat these real quick.
I can't do this.
Is that my green room?
427.
That's me.
I am amongst the greats.
I can't...
I don't deserve to be here.
Okay.
Hold on.
Let's look over what I said.
My notes.
Stanley.
Me.
Dad.
Age 6.
Story.
Son is...
Son is wanting me to do a good job.
Break a leg champ.
Your boss.
Thanks boss.
Stanley.
My true love for you grows every day.
You make me feel alive.
Your wife from the...
Experiment depart...
Wait.
Oh from the...
From the...
Experiment ending.
We have a wife.
I love the way you ride elevators.
XX.
We are cheating on our wife.
That I just learned that we had.
No one tells stories the way you do.
Go get them tiger.
Thanks for showing me that cool skateboard trick.
In the parking lot.
You are too cool.
Good luck on stage.
Rock on.
Break a leg champ.
Your boss.
They wrote two notes.
They are so kind.
Thanks for showing me that cool skateboard trick.
Reminds me.
You know when someone tweets something.
And then everybody replies to that.
To kind of hype them up.
Just like thanks for letting me borrow your Mercedes.
And saving me from the...
It's the same vibes I'm getting.
The freedom ending.
Adventure.
I went to the mind control facility.
And all I got was this lousy sticker.
Congratulations Stanley.
Remember where you came from.
Your co-workers.
We got a little golf thing.
And everything.
I can hear the people.
They are waiting for me.
You can do this.
Peter Piper picked a peck of pickle peppers.
Oh wait, I didn't even get to the end.
Is it WrestleTuber 2025 already?
Just like a WrestleTuber.
This fucked me for a long time, but...
How were they already...
Already what?
Oh sorry, hold on.
I couldn't see it.
Already pickled when he picked them.
Doesn't add up.
So true.
Was it all just a dream?
Every time I...
I say every time...
I was gonna say every time I play this game.
Which I have not...
I don't wanna make it seem like I've played it a lot.
But I always...
I guess maybe every loop I expect to see a person.
You know what I mean?
It's new.
Like Exit 8?
Yes, yes, yes.
Maybe you just haven't found the right path yet.
Oh.
New content?
What does that mean?
I don't know.
You tell me.
Another elevator, my favorite.
Oh.
Okay.
It's like a ride.
It's like a theme park ride.
Hello and thank you for playing the Stanley Parable Ultra Deluxe.
As you may know, the Stanley Parable was a video game released in 2013 on home computers.
After receiving critical and commercial success, it was expanded upon in 2022 with the Stanley Parable Ultra Deluxe, a reimagining of the game for consoles and home computers.
Home computers.
That's me.
That's where I'm at.
Well, I'm gonna make it happen.
This is my home.
The Stanley Parable Ultra Deluxe features exciting new content that broadens and expands the world of the Stanley Parable.
More games.
Delighting audiences the world over.
Happy.
Let's step inside and see what thrilling new adventures await in the Stanley Parable Ultra Deluxe.
Wow.
This sounds delightful.
I'm very excited to see the thrilling new Ultra Deluxe content.
Me too.
Though I'm pretty sure I did this before.
But that's okay.
I don't remember.
I really don't remember you so bad.
I'm sure it's just the beginning of a mesmerizing adventure.
Cat potato.
Welcome to the membership.
Thank you.
Uh.
Is it broken?
What's going on here?
Should we...
Should we be moving somewhere or...
Oh.
There we go.
All right.
Finally.
At long last.
It's on to the new content.
I've never been more ready.
Let's do it.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
I'm so excited.
Because there's so much content.
It's true.
This game is really crazy.
I have to say, initial impressions of Stanley Parable Ultra Deluxe, mostly tedious.
It's as if the...
Hmm.
Oh, okay.
Let's see the content.
Give me the content, Stanley.
Oh my gosh.
I'm a content creator.
I can give that to you.
Now thinking about it.
Thinking about like some of the endings that I remember.
There's one in particular that I remember that was like...
Oh.
You like sit in a room and like thousands of years go by and stuff like that.
That's the only one I remember.
Wait.
Is this the room?
Uh-oh.
Oh.
Wait.
Uh.
No.
All right.
Let's see.
It's the jump circle.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
No.
I think I jumped enough.
Is that it?
No.
Surely that's not all the new content.
There has to be something else, right?
Oh, there's all...
Okay.
Hold on.
I'm going to finish it.
Jumping.
Save the jumps?
Oh.
Okay.
Another elevator.
Stanley, I have to say, initial impressions of this game are not...
My stream is so wasteful.
It's just elevators and jumping.
Is this what passes for exciting new content?
I know.
I know that you guys are excited but also try not to like backseat too much.
I do.
I do want to experience things on my own as well.
So...
If I screw up, that's up to me.
You know what I mean?
Okay.
I knew there had to be something else.
Let's see it.
I'm ready for whatever it is.
Oh.
The abyss.
The abyss office.
Thank you for enjoying the new content.
That's it?
Oh, you've got to be kidding me.
You see, Stanley?
This is what happens when greedy video game developers with no respect for their fan base rush a cheap expansion to market for no reason other than to make an easy dollar.
Classic abyss room.
Classic.
And don't get misguided on the level of craftsmanship that's gone into it.
My office had three.
In fact, I'm looking right now at the game's achievements and it's hard to believe one of them actually says, test achievement, please ignore.
What quality assurance department signed off on this?
Can I get that one?
I haven't gotten a single achievement, actually.
I'm infuriated and I'm offended and I intend to find these people on Twitter and hold them personally accountable.
Formally, Twitter.
It's my fault, Stanley.
I built up too much anticipation around the new content, I'm afraid.
It could never have lived up to such expectations.
Speak the truth.
If you're still with me, why don't we just reset the game and we'll try to get back to what the Stanley Parable is really about.
No frills.
No gimmicks.
Just you and me having a great time together, like always.
What do you say, friend?
Oh.
It's a little different.
That's my office.
That's where I'm supposed to be in this very moment.
Okay.
Fascinating.
Psst.
Stanley, come over here.
In the vent.
I want to show you something.
Ew.
It's like...
It's like it.
It's so sus.
What if I don't listen to him?
Let's see.
Let's try this.
Oh.
You don't want to see the cool surprise I made for you?
Well, fine.
Oh, surprise?
You're a dork anyway, so who cares?
Excuse...
Oh.
Oh, what?
Are you saying that I'm not, like, cool enough to go through?
Oh.
Never mind.
You're not a dork.
I think I heard something.
I think I have to go.
When Stanley came to a set of two open doors, he entered the door on his left.
This was not the correct way to the meeting room.
I'm not listening to you at all.
And Stanley knew it perfectly well.
I'm not listening to you to do anything.
Perhaps he wanted to stop by the employee lounge first.
At all.
Just to admire it.
No.
Wow.
I'm just going to keep going.
Yes.
This room.
Screw you.
Call me.
Yep.
Stanley took the first open door on his left.
La, la, la, la.
I'm not done.
I'm not listening to anything you say any longer.
Stanley was so bad at following directions, it's incredible he wasn't fired years ago.
Do not lie.
If you are lying right now, stop.
Okay.
What if I told you my real name wasn't really Mint Phantom?
What if I told you that I named myself that when I came back from consciousness after dying because I had a spearmint in my tummy?
Do not jump from cargo, Liz.
Cargo lift while it is in motion will cause death.
Penalty for misuse of cargo lift 1000.
Penalty for jumping off the cargo lift 5000.
Look, Stanley.
I think perhaps we've gotten off on the wrong foot here.
I'm not your enemy.
Really, I'm not.
There's the exit.
I realize investing your trust in someone else can be difficult, but the fact is that the story has been about nothing but you all this time.
There's someone you've been neglecting, Stanley.
Someone you've forgotten about.
Really?
I'm sorry.
I was in the middle of something.
Do you have zero consideration for others?
Are you that convinced that I want something bad to happen to you?
Why, I don't know how to convince you of this, but I really do want to help you.
To show you something beautiful.
Look, let me prove it.
Let me prove that I'm on your side.
Give me a chance.
I'm no dork.
What are we, in a relationship?
Now, right?
Or...
Ghosts don't know.
No followers.
Yeah.
No buckets past this point.
Now listen carefully.
This is important.
Stanley walked through the red door.
This one has a swipe... a key card.
Hmm.
Um.
Aha.
Perhaps you misunderstood.
Stanley walked through the red door.
I'm sorry.
He just picked me up like I was a goddamn sim.
I'm colorblind.
I'm colorblind!
Oh!
I still don't think we're communicating properly.
Stanley walked through the red door.
Red door.
Door, door, door, door, door, door, door.
Door, door, door, door, door, door, door, door.
All right.
Fine.
Go ahead, Stanley.
You want to know so badly what's out there?
You want to find out what lies at the end of this road?
You've chosen...
Yeah!
Don't let me stop you.
Oh, I do.
Oh.
Wait.
Is...
Is this the place that I got spoiled before?
You see?
There's nothing here.
Oh.
I haven't even finished building this section of the map.
Because you were never supposed to be here in the first place.
Oh.
Broken rooms.
Exposed developer textures.
Oh, that's true.
Is this what you had wanted?
Was it worth ruining the entire story I had written out specifically for you?
Do you not think I put a lot of time into that?
Because I did.
And in the end, it was all for nothing.
When do we get to the baby?
Because this is what you wanted to see.
Baby.
Help me here, Stanley.
Help elucidate these strange and unknowable desires of yours.
What would have made this game better?
A baby.
What did you want to see?
Anime.
Vehicles?
Skill tree?
Skill tree.
Work with me.
You give me absolutely nothing so far.
Give me Minecraft.
Tell you what.
Let me take a stab in the dark at a new design and you can give me some feedback.
There we go.
A third option.
This already feels leaps ahead of where we were before.
Go ahead, Stanley.
Take it for a spin.
Okay.
Oh.
I'm going to stop you there.
Now, tell me about your experience with this new version.
Would you say that the game benefited from allowing you more choices?
Feel free to be honest.
I'm looking for some real critical feedback here.
Five is the best or one is the best?
You gotta tell me which is the best.
Five or one?
Disagree?
Highly disagree?
Highly agree?
Hmm.
A one?
I mean, I can understand if you had reservations.
You saw ways the game could be improved to more fully express itself mechanically and artistically.
But a one?
A one?
That's not even helpful.
What am I supposed to do with that?
Hmm.
But I guess it isn't my place to judge.
Here, based on the data from your previous play through, I've compiled a new version.
Okay.
And if you're perfectly candid, I think I've knocked it out of the park with this one.
Let's take a look.
Okay.
Oh.
Now, would you say that competitive leaderboard helped you feel motivated to keep walking through doors?
Again, honest answers, please.
Wait.
Are these real people?
No.
Oh, no.
Okay.
21.3% of players skipped the intro sequence.
That's a dead rat!
Oh,
a dead rat!
How long does it take you to get to the correct place?
Wow,
I don't have any progress.
The time comes.
Yeah.
One on one.
I open the door and go out all of a sudden and come out.
Apparently everyone is hit.
Uh-oh.
Happy Memorial Day, Mint.
Eat anything.
What what?
Go today at Barbecue Roops for dinner.
Yummy!
I bugged the game.
You can't jump.
No, seriously.
We disabled it.
Get your first achievement.
I didn't try jumping!
I tried moving!
Uh-oh.
Uh, I think I have to restart.
I think I have to restart.
Oh, no!
I actually broke the game!
Okay, a dead rat wouldn't have gotten stuck.
That's why he's 9,327.
I'm a dead rat.
Oh, she's a dead rat.
I would never softlock their game.
No!
Rip Bozo.
Congrats, you got the closet.
Oh, here we go.
We could go through here if we wanted.
Psst!
Stanley, come over here.
In the vent.
I want to show you something.
What should we do, guys?
Should we go through the vent or should we...
Are you still a dork?
No.
I don't think so.
The narrator's a dork, obviously.
Coffee nut!
Wow.
This is pretty cinematic.
Here I go.
Okay, nice.
Okay, you remember how cheap and unsatisfying the new Ultra Deluxe content turned out to be.
Well, it got me thinking about the past.
And how much better the Stanley Parable used to be.
So I made something special and tucked it away here where the game's developers won't find it.
Elden Ring!
Just our little secret.
Just kidding.
I call it the Memory Zone.
Wow.
It's where I've been storing all my favorite memories.
Oh my god.
Where I can relive the peak experiences of my life whenever I want.
Guy lives in the past.
Experiences like the launch of the Stanley Parable on PC.
Wow.
You see, Stanley, doesn't the Memory Zone remind you of how wonderful Stanley Parable was before it was sullied with a cheap re-release?
Oh, audiences.
Cheap, cheap.
Remember back in October of 2013 when the game originally launched?
The British Academy of Film and Television Arts.
Back then, video games had integrity.
Back then, it all meant something.
Oh, the waste.
Memory, sweet memory.
Oh my god, Steam Page!
That's so funny.
Ah, 2013, when the Stanley Parable was released.
Life was so much more simple back in 2013.
Especially because the Stanley Parable was just released.
Oh, I was gonna say this is the actual time, but it is not.
Our first kiss.
My first car.
The release of the Stanley Parable in 2013.
Scripts.
Stanley Parable on Steam.
Oh no, just kidding.
The website.
The original remake.
Good times.
Oh, I've seen...
Oh, the mind control facility.
Oh, the two doors.
Oh my gosh, this has been so long.
Why is this roped off?
Am I in a bad spot?
Smile because it happened.
Their first dollar!
Or just a dollar, who knows.
The demo, wow.
2013.
That means they announced Half Life 3.
No, they didn't.
Go outside?
Don't play for five years?
Stanley Parable Alpha Test.
More British stuff.
British.
I'm glad they've been nominated a lot.
Stanley Parable deals, tough choices.
Oh, he's dead!
Wait, there's another person.
Is that her wife?
The flowers are so hard.
Little Stanley?
Ah, little Stanley.
Oh!
It's Adele.
Never mind, I'll find someone like you.
And over here is where I keep reviews of the Stanley Parable.
Wow!
Yeah, with the full middle name.
Every game!
Persona 3!
That's so relevant now!
A husk.
A shell of itself.
So sad.
Wow.
What's going on?
Maintenance.
Can't go in there.
Knowing your city.
Old pictures and stuff.
The original remake.
Person of the year?
That's me!
Is that my wife?
Who is that?
Petscop.
Collector's edition.
Isn't that a tie?
It's so cute.
The greatest wealth is memory.
The red and the blue door!
We just saw the happy button.
I don't think we've heard that yet.
Here's another moving passage.
This time from GameSpot.com.
GameSpot.
The Stanley Parable is both a richly stimulating commentary on the nature of choice in games, and one that offers some of the most enjoyable, surprising, and rewarding choices I've ever been confronted with in a game.
Nine out of ten.
Don't you get it, Stanley?
The game was perfect.
I didn't need anything else.
It didn't need new content.
It just needed to be left alone.
To spend the rest of time collecting dust in the hallowed hall of beloved video game memories.
Aww.
Yeah, it didn't need anything else.
Oh my gosh.
The Himmel the Hero joke made me think, like literally, I think it was like yesterday, I was thinking, I was like, man, I guess, you know, eventually Himmel the Hero jokes will like get old, but then we can just make the new joke, Himmel the Hero, loved Himmel the Hero jokes.
So it will never get old.
What's this?
Oh, is this the collector?
Oh no, this is the carpet textures.
Ready for your game project.
Wow.
The serious room.
What is the...
What is Kiara's room called again?
What is that one called again?
The...
The usual room?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's the usual room.
Can I go through here?
Where am I supposed to go?
I went through here, didn't I?
These were simpler times, Stanley.
Oh, down here.
But I wouldn't give to go back to have it all over again.
I know.
Wait.
Hang on.
Yeah?
I don't recall this part of the memory zone before.
What's this?
What's down here?
Oh.
Whoa.
Oh, no.
God, no.
Stanley, it's a collection of reviews from Steam.
The online video game distributor.
I haven't looked at these in years.
I think I vaguely remember this part.
I can't even imagine what's being collected down here.
Oh, God.
Surely these reviews were glaring as well, weren't they?
Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah, baby.
Steam reviews are my...
Oh, boy.
Honestly, I could not be bothered to play this game to full completion.
Oh, no.
The narrator is obnoxious and unfunny.
Unfunny.
With his humor and dialogue proving to be more irritating than entertaining.
I'm not trying to be funny.
I'm trying to make a serious work of art.
I suppose I could write up a handful of gags to insert into the Stanley parable, but the game is already such a densely-layered web of profound philosophical insights that I can't even imagine where I'd have the room to stick them in.
This one's a positive one.
Don't let one bad review get you down.
Don't worry about it.
You know, it's so funny.
This comment didn't inspire me to play this today.
But I saw it coming.
I saw a comment earlier that someone left for me that was just like, Quit your job?
You quit your job for this?
Go back to being an OL.
I was like, you know what?
I was already going to play the Stanley parable.
So, it's also perfect.
They were like, YouTube isn't forever.
Go back to your old job.
You'll have no life skills.
I think he was on to something.
I think so, too.
Oh, it's getting really rainy.
Ew, dead bodies are in here for sure.
Oh, this is...
Oh.
Okay, let's see what this one says.
You're reading all the bad ones.
All the good ones are in here, too.
For someone who prefers non-linear games, this preachiness gets annoying fast.
Preachy?
Stanley?
I'm not preachy, am I?
Just a little.
You can tell me if I'm preachy.
Honestly, you can.
I'm telling you.
This is actually quite shocking for me.
I always will.
To be honest, I had always...
There's good ones right here.
Oh, there's not that many.
It's been rather terse to begin with.
You can't know how much fluff I cut from the game to get it to feel as light and airy as it...
Well, I always thought it did.
But maybe it wasn't.
Maybe it wasn't.
What an awful memory to have to hold on to.
These black marks are my otherwise unimpeachable track record.
I mean...
I feel like a failure.
No!
Like I let these people down.
There's good reviews right there!
Perhaps the Stanley Parable isn't quite as sterling as I always remembered.
Uh-oh.
I mean, there's no such thing as a perfect game except Metal Gear Solid.
So, you know, you can't help it.
You know, you'll never be Metal Gear.
You know?
What's this one got to say?
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do.
You constantly have to stop doing anything so the narrator can hear you.
You can catch up with his long-winded explanations of what's happening.
I wish there was a skip button.
A skip button.
Well, yes.
Yes, I think we can do that.
If I'm truly too preachy, then maybe letting you skip ahead for just a moment, surely it couldn't hurt.
Surely.
Not if it means we can strike these negative reviews from the record.
Only positive reviews of the Stanley Parable.
That's my motto today and it's always been my motto.
I'd do anything for the company.
Wow.
The customer is always right.
A skip button.
Oh!
I think this is that ending.
Because we keep pressing the skip button, right?
And then we skip to the end of the life, end of the world?
And here it is.
Go ahead and give it a shot.
I'll pop you forward in time so that the second my incessant droning starts to bore you, with just the push of a button, you'll have zipped right past it.
Spoilers.
I'm back!
Oh, you're back, you see?
Yeah!
You were only frozen in time for a few minutes, but it was plenty of time for me to deliver a long rambling monologue full of unnecessary verbal flourishes and lengthy ruminations for the nature of choice in video games.
One o'clock.
Of course, I happen to believe it was perhaps one of my more profound such ruminations.
Not that of course you need it.
Well there, sport.
I'm back!
You did catch me rambling on a bit, didn't you?
I did.
But that's the power of the button.
The minute I start to go off on a thoughtless display of self-absorption, it's right at your fingertips to go poof!
And it's all over!
It's all over!
Oh, I can't wait to see what Cookie9 will say about this.
Oh, he's probably, like, static.
And whether they'll edit the rating of their Steam review, or at least change some of the wording, perhaps.
To be honest, I don't even know if one can change their review in the first place.
Can you?
Actually, I don't know either.
I never leave reviews.
I guess I should become better educated on exactly how Steam works.
Perhaps that would have been the right thing to do.
This one's for you, Cookie9!
Oh, you can.
Now, I should say that the amount of time the button has been skipping through is becoming longer and longer.
That last one was, well, I want to say maybe 30, 45 minutes?
Oh!
It's not unendurable by any means, but it's, well, there's really only so much I can ramble on to myself about.
I know, it's shocking, isn't it?
But at any rate, I do suggest that we not pause the video.
I'm not going to press the button again.
Have you seen the Helldiver 2 reviews?
I have not.
I think the skip button has been aptly demonstrated, and we can say goodbye to it and just... wait.
How do we get out of here?
Yeah, there's a...
Oh!
Where did the door go?
Wasn't there a door that led into this room?
There was!
I don't feel quite certain.
Now, Ryder, now, Ryder, what do we do?
How else would we have gotten into the room in the first place?
I don't think one can enter a room without a door of some sort or a window or something like that.
We can go through the ceiling.
Do you see a window anywhere?
A porthole?
No.
A sufficiently large crack in the wall?
I'll take any of these.
All I want is for us to move on.
Let's just move on.
Yeah.
Let's just...
Stanley!
Yeah?
Stanley, please don't push the button again!
It's been 12 hours!
12 hours?
You've just been frozen there.
I don't know why the skips are getting longer, but they're really, truly getting longer, and my God, there's no way out of the room.
Uh-oh.
Stanley, the door is gone.
It's completely gone.
I have skipping Genshin impact cutscenes.
I've looked at it from every angle.
I've checked every one of those walls a thousand times.
I've only played Genshin, like, once, so...
And there's no door standing.
Hi.
I don't quite know.
There's no door.
There's just you and the button, and if you keep pressing it, I have no idea...
Okay.
Oh, Stanley.
You're back.
I'm back.
Oh, my goodness.
I have someone to talk to again.
Stanley, I...
I think it's been a week.
A week?
For two weeks.
I've been sitting here all that time.
Just sitting here.
Not a single person to speak with.
And you'd think that that's just how it's always been, right?
I'm looking for my stool.
Oh, there it is.
Me talking, and you saying...
I'm saying nothing.
Would you think that it's exactly the same as always?
Doesn't that feel like what we've already been doing?
Me just talking?
But it isn't, Stanley.
It isn't the same at all.
It isn't even close.
Because I know you can't hear me once you push that button.
No.
That's what I'm realizing now, Stanley.
Not at all.
I'm realizing that I needed to know that someone was listening.
Oh.
I needed there to be a vessel through which my words were moving.
Yeah.
It was them.
Oh.
Right.
Hello, it's you.
Hi.
Welcome.
I have had time to think about you and about us and about everything we've been through.
About us?
I've had so much time, I stopped keeping track after a year.
Oh, you?
I haven't sat down in one place and not moved for one entire year.
Let me describe it for you.
To begin with, there is only regret.
What?
He talks like we're in a relationship.
Like, what is going on with us?
I feel like I'm in the corner.
You know, I'm sorry I ghosted you for a year, but I just can't help it, I'm a ghost!
Well, why didn't you leave?
You're not stuck here too, either, are you?
A business ghost?
What business are we in?
Is this the business of misery?
Let's take it from the top.
Good morning!
Narrator!
Has that always been there?
Narrator?
Hello?
I'm alive!
Are you alive?
I don't know how this twig is still sitting up, you know?
Think he's dead, Jim?
No, he's not.
He's taking a nap at this time, too.
I'll see him.
I'll see him in the next skip.
Oh, that's terrible.
Oh, my God.
Oh, that's terrible!
That's terrible, terrible noise!
Uh, the clock is off the wall.
But they didn't understand.
The game was never meant to be funny.
Oh, he's alive!
It was meant to have a point.
It was meant to speak to the human condition.
But where are the jokes?
Where are the jokes?
They bemoaned, they screamed, they gnashed their teeth and said, entertain us!
It wasn't enough.
They had to leave a pathetic little thumbs-down review and make all of their pitiful demands.
But then...
He's talking too much, Stacy!
I told you he was taking a nap!
First, he didn't entertain us.
Now he won't shut up!
It's the inconsistency.
It's the lack of accountability.
Yeah, okay!
It's the unwillingness to examine with an uncompromising heart...
Yeah, tell them!
Go off on them, narrator!
...the words that they are speaking into the world.
Yeah!
Yeah, shake them!
As though there were no consequences for a lack of cohesion in one's assessment of others.
Shake them in their feelings!
Tell them that they're stupid and wrong!
So here's what we get.
We get these demands that seek everything and are accountable to nothing.
We get a world where someone will say, oh, there should be a skip button.
There should be a skip button!
You should be able to freeze Stanley in place while the narrator sits there forever and ever.
We want all of this in the new Stanley parable.
We demand it!
And then, because it was said, because it was spoken, now it simply has to happen.
You made this!
The most immediate...
He's asleep again.
It's fine, you guys.
I wonder how long it's been.
Oh.
It takes a second.
There we go.
I like to check.
I don't know if there's anything each time.
Anything different, but I like to check.
He was... He's still just asleep, you know?
He's still fine.
He just took a nap, too.
The end is never the end, is never the end, is never the end, is never the end, is never the end, is never the end, is never the end, is never the end...
Oh, I can finally get a drink.
Drink!
It's never the end, it's never the end...
pagi Good morning!
Oh, it's really leaking now.
Uh oh, it's a little bit moldy.
Smells nasty in here.
Why do I smell so nasty?
I'm getting a shower.
How long do you guys think it's been at this point?
How many years?
It collapsed from the water.
It's kind of dangerous, maybe.
It's never the end.
500?
I thought I was going to sneeze.
Please, just let me sneeze!
Sometimes I need to sneeze, and even when I need to sneeze off stream, I can't sneeze still.
It's the worst feeling ever.
Oh!
It's daylight.
Oh my god, I don't know the last time I've seen the daylight!
Wow.
Oh.
There's flies?
Is there a dead body here?
Is it me or is it attached to me?
It's because I'm really gross.
But I showered like 5000 years ago!
What's wrong?
Why do I hear flies?
I showered, I showered!
Oh!
Whoa!
Nature...
Nature prevails.
Whoa!
It's taken back over!
Nature is healing!
Tokyo Jungle.
Oh.
No!
I
forgot how eerie this one really gets.
This one's really freaky.
So if you die before you get a chance to shower, does that mean you're forever stinky as a ghost for all eternity?
No!
I wash my ectoplasm almost every day.
Stinky ghost.
Takes one to know one.
Whoa, why am I like sideways?
Oh!
I think we're sideways!
We're crooked!
Why can't we see...
Why is there...
Why can't we see through here anymore, but there's light over here?
Oh, the button's down!
The button's down!
I repeat!
The button is down!
Oh.
Whoa!
That's it.
But it's okay.
Life will be reborn on this lifeless planet.
Me.
I'll start it.
I will spread my seed across the world.
I will rebuild this planet as one.
Everybody will become Stanley.
Stanleyfication.
From sea to shining sea!
I think it worked!
Good job, guys!
What are those...
What are those emojis that are happening?
What is that?
Thanks for the donut, though.
No, I don't want to be Stanley!
All of his co-workers were gone.
What could it mean?
Stanley decided to go to the meeting room.
Perhaps he had simply missed a memo.
Stanley...
Oh!
New...
New content!
I feel like...
Okay.
As silly as this sounds...
Stanley Beyond Journey's End.
I don't think I've ever gotten like the normal ending.
Like the...
Like...
We follow all his prompts.
We follow everything.
I don't think I've ever gotten that one before.
I think I've always just instinctually went against the...
The...
The narrator.
Let's just listen to what he has to say.
When Stanley came to a set of two open doors, he entered the door on his left.
Yeah!
We're gonna...
We're gonna follow the rules.
We're gonna follow...
We're gonna be a little...
We're gonna...
We're not gonna be...
We're not adventurous at all.
I'm just a little Stanley.
This is shitty Stanley.
Yet there was not a single person here either.
Feeling a wave of disbelief, Stanley decided to go up to his boss's office, hoping he might find an answer there.
This is Stanley...
Coming to a staircase, Stanley walked upstairs to his office.
This is Stanley, the Good Stanley.
This is...
This is Timid Stanley.
As it is written...
Oh, forgot about the bathroom.
Money in the morning...
Money in the evening...
Money for breakfast...
Money crisp...
today.
NPC Stanley.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Thank you for your super chat, by the way.
Thank you.
Stepping into his manager's office, Stanley started...
None.
To nobody.
Keypad.
Wow.
Uh-oh, wait.
I pressed 4!
Amazing.
That's kind of crazy.
He's not talking to me at all.
I should have put in boob.
I should have put in boob!
8-0-0-8.
Was this here before or did I just not notice it?
Escape.
No, no.
We're NPC Stanley.
Beep.
The lights rose on an enormous room packed with television screens.
Wow.
What horrible secret did this place hold?
Stanley thought to himself.
Did he have the strength to find out?
I almost just fell.
Why did they allow you?
Oh my god.
Why did they allow you to do that?
No way.
Do it.
Eee!
Aha.
You've made it to the bottom of the mind control facility.
Welcome.
You see, back when the Stanley Parable first launched in 2013, getting to the bottom of the mind control facility was a bug that we simply didn't catch during development.
Oh, no way.
Do a flip.
And you all sent us lots of photos of it on Twitter and acted very superior about it.
And you're all very, very clever.
Good for you.
Thank you.
Anyway, when it came time to update the game, we knew that we had to do something about it.
Hmm.
Silly guys.
Here you go.
New content.
New content?
You can call it the bottom of the mind control room ending if that enhances your perception of the value of these updates.
Okay.
Yes.
Isn't that what you crave?
New content?
Yes.
Always more content.
More content.
More, more, more, more, more, more.
Oh, nom, nom, nom.
I'm eating all this content.
I'm so full.
Oh my god.
I'm fat from content.
Thank you.
I'm here to make it seem like we've really covered every nook and cranny of the game with secrets and Easter eggs.
How about this?
We wrote a new piece of music just for this section.
Ooh.
You won't hear it anywhere else in the game.
Okay.
It's a secret that's just for you.
More, more, more.
That's how special you are.
We call this track, Good Job.
You made it to the bottom of the mind control facility.
Laugh and grow fat, Mito.
Content and grow fat.
You did it.
Good job.
Me?
Yeah.
Three, two, one.
Good job.
You made it to the bottom of the mind control facility.
Ooh.
You jumped on the catwalk.
You should have been careful.
I should have been careful.
It used to be a bug.
A bug.
But now it's an ending.
Yeah, now it's ending.
I believe in you.
I believe in your ability to cross this barrier.
And chase your dreams.
But railings don't mean anything.
Good job.
You did it.
I didn't get the normal ending.
I thought he would teleport me back or something, you know?
Oopsie.
Good job!
You did it!
So glad I made a sequel to You Have to Burn the Rope.
Okay, la la la, we're gonna get the normal ending this time!
NPC mission failed!
No, no.
He entered the door on his left.
On his left, on his left, on his left.
Then we'll go to the new new content.
Yet there was not a single person here either.
I think the new new content is where...
Stanley decided to go up to his boss's office.
I think that's where I broke the game before.
The moment he entered his manager's office, Stanley froze in his tracks.
Wait.
I messed up.
Could he really be all alone?
This was too much for Stanley to take.
Too much for...
Stanley was in such a rush to get through the story as quickly as possible...
Come on!
He didn't even have a single minute to just let the narrator talk.
No time to talk, buddy!
No time to talk!
Boo!
With some calming New Age music...
Okay.
We're getting the whole soundtrack this time.
Feeling soothed and rejuvenated, Stanley calmly walked forward...
Did you get the broom closet ending?
My favorite!
Oh!
The broom closet ending!
My favorite!
Please, sir.
Can I have another broom closet ending?
It wouldn't let you speed run it.
Oh, not at all.
It's okay.
I get it.
They're keeping to a very strict schedule.
Stanley walked straight ahead through the large door that read, Mind Control Facility.
Oh, it's really tempting.
It's written in Koran and everything.
You know it was hastily done.
This is fine.
That's fine.
Okay, push the button.
Alright.
True NPC ending.
Here we go!
The lights rose on an enormous room packed with television screens.
What horrible things.
What little secret did this place hold?
Stanley thought to himself.
Did he have the strength to find out?
I kind of want to hear this song again, but I won't do it.
Sorry, you guys.
Crayon!
Okay, are you happy?
Oh my god.
I can't say anything without getting judged by your insignificant details.
Now the monitors jump to life.
Their true nature revealed.
I never saw this before.
A number of an employee in the building.
Stanley's co-workers.
The lives of so many individuals reduced to images on a screen.
Reduced?
They've been reduced.
Where freedom meant nothing.
What is that one right there?
The one that's blue.
Oh, it's just kind of normal.
Reduced to nothing.
What's this?
A control facility.
It was too horrible to believe.
It couldn't be true.
Well, where are they?
Have you been under someone's control all this time?
Was this the only reason he was happy with his boring job?
That his emotions had been manipulated to accept it blindly?
No.
I love my job.
He refused to believe it.
He couldn't accept it.
His own life in someone else's control?
Never.
Never?
It was unthinkable, wasn't it?
Was it even possible?
My life?
I control my own fate.
Utterly blind to the world?
But here was the proof.
The heart of the operation.
Controls labeled with emotions.
Happy or sad or content.
Walking, eating, working.
They controlled everything.
All of it monitored and commanded from this very place.
And as the cold reality of his past, began to sink in.
Stanley decided that this machinery would never again exert its terrible power over another human life.
Never again.
For he would dismantle the controls once and for all.
Mind controls idle awaiting input.
But who stopped it?
I need a Stanley Parable 2.
A prequel to this.
Uh-oh.
Don't give me a choice here.
The Patriots.
MPC Mint, remember?
You're right, you're right.
Scared me.
MPC!
Shut down GW.
We went through a microwave tunnel for this.
Was it over?
Yes.
He had won.
He had defeated the machine.
Unshackled himself from someone else's command.
Freedom was mere moments away.
And yet, even as the immense door slowly opened, Stanley reflected on how many puzzles still lay unsolved.
Where had his co-workers gone?
How had he been freed from the machine's grasp?
What other mysteries did this strange building hold?
But as sunlight streamed into the chamber, he realized none of this mattered to him.
For it was not knowledge or even power that he had been seeking, but happiness.
Perhaps his goal had not been to understand, but to let go.
No longer would anyone tell him where to go, what to do, or how to feel.
Whatever life he lives, it will be his.
And that was all he needed to know.
It was, perhaps, the only thing worth knowing.
Let me out.
Stanley stepped through the open door.
Grass.
Oh, I didn't even do anything.
The feeling of liberation.
The immense possibility of the new path before him.
That's beautiful.
This was exactly the way, right now, that things were meant to happen.
Wow.
And Stanley was happy.
Wow, it's like a...
Actually, it's just like a wholesome...
Complete the Stanley Parable.
Maybe we should have done this last.
It's actually like such a nice ending.
Wow.
It's like so like...
Stanley was happy.
Oh, well, back in the office for you, bozo.
You can never leave the office alive.
Just a step through this door, Stanley thought to himself, that's all I need.
If I can make it through this door, I can make it through them all.
Wait, what?
Can I?
No.
Stanley went around touching every little thing in the office.
You just told me I can go through the doors.
But it didn't make a single difference.
Nor did it advance the story in any way.
New, new content.
Oh, good.
You noticed my sign.
I did.
Yes, I have something very exciting to show you.
Okay.
Through here?
Alright, we're going through our little ride again.
Love it.
New, new content.
Wait, but I wanted to see the...
I wanted to see the ride again.
World turning the button on results in...
Mintification?
I've been reflecting on the Stanley Parable.
And about how roundly disappointing this Ultra Deluxe version has turned out to be.
The original Stanley Parable was a landmark.
And any new content for it should live up to that legacy.
So forget this Ultra Deluxe nonsense.
I say we take it one step even further.
Which is why I'm very proud to announce for the first time ever...
Is this supposed to look like this?
The Stanley Parable 2.
Two!
Oh, I think I remember this part.
Far superior to a measly re-release with a few minor additions.
Think of all the new territory we'll cover with a fully fledged sequel.
An entirely new experience built from the ground up.
Why there are so many possibilities.
It could go in so many different directions.
Two, two, that's me.
This is what fans have truly been asking for.
Investor Showcase!
Oh, yeah, baby.
Two, two, two, two, two, two, two.
Okay.
Calling it the Stanley Parable 2 is just so much catchier than Ultra Deluxe, don't you think?
Sure.
Ultra Deluxe?
What does it even mean?
But the Stanley Parable 2.
Off page.
Now that's an artistic statement right there.
What's a TGA file?
It's future oriented.
It means progress and innovation and long term franchising potential.
Potential.
Targa.
What's Targa?
Type of... texture file.
Interesting.
Wow, this is so fancy.
It's like a whole new...
Like, I mean, it is a whole new office.
We got modern stone concrete wall aesthetic and they're back.
The two doors.
I love those guys.
I love
those guys.
New content is out.
New content part two is it.
What's this?
Sequel ideas.
Stanley can throw axes?
Stanley gets boons from fish?
Artistic.
Intimate wipe scene.
Free room.
Oh, free roam.
Free roam made.
More famous narrator.
That one's crossed out.
Dress up mode.
Code.
Noob.
Microtransactions.
Very good.
Proper gameplay?
Noob.
Stanley.
New York City.
Jetpack.
Fuel canisters?
Whoever wrote this is on to something great.
Whoever wrote that...
Oh, I can't read the two.
Meeting at 2 p.m..
Yeah,
I'm needing some of these.
Especially the... several of them.
More TSP.
Better TSP.
Paradigm Shift S-Energy.
Brick and Mortar Approach.
The color red.
Sequential Mindshare.
Win-win.
The ferns!
Wait.
I don't know anything about... Oh my gosh.
Look at that.
Oh, I kinda like this one down here.
I kinda like the Stanley Parable with the two lines inside.
Thanks for attending my meeting.
The other ones are whatever.
The second one reminds me of Red Dead Redemption, I think.
I never had an ending with the ferns.
Oh, I thought this was nude Stanley.
Now to be clear, I haven't quite nailed down what exactly the Stanley Parable 2 is going to be.
But let's take a look at some of the features I've been developing for it.
Okay.
I figure that if I can loosely organize a handful of interesting concepts, that surely the game will sort of naturally spring up around them.
It'll all work itself out.
Game development is much more of a fuzzy magic than anything scientific or logical.
This is so relatable.
Two eyes.
Two ears.
Two nostrils.
Two arms.
Two legs.
What the perfect Stanley.
The end is never the end again!
Stanley Parable 2, now with blockchain and AI.
Noooo!
Sequels are good!
Portal 2, Half-Life 2, Batman Arkham Asylum 2, Metal Gear Solid 2...
Doom 2...
Divinity Original...
Original Sin 2?
Aladdin 2?
Return of Jafar?
Dark Souls 2?
Hmm...
Doom 2...
The prequel to the Stanley Parable.
2 is the sequel to the Stanley Parable.
Is the prequel to the Stanley Parable.
Is the prequel...
2.
Nice...
Every pause button is a Roman numeral 2.
The show floor.
Wow!
Yeah!
Thank you!
What are you wearing tonight, Mint?
I'm wearing your mom's dress from last night!
Thank you!
No other questions!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Oh god.
Wow!
I do remember this part a little bit.
Hear your name in the game.
The button that says the name of the player that is playing the game!
For the Stanley Parable 2, I asked myself what do players really want?
And of course, The first and most obvious answer is that they want to be individually recognized and validated as people.
So with that in mind, my first addition to the game is this button which speaks the name of the person playing the game.
Isn't that wonderful?
I remember the last time this did not say my name.
Thanks for the super chat, I'm glad I could make you smile.
It's gonna say Mint.
And if it doesn't say any... if it says anything else...
If it says anything else, it's the Doc's button.
You guys are scaring me.
It's going to say Mint.
Going to say Mint.
Jim.
Sorry, I should have clarified.
Right now, the button only says the name Jim.
But of course, in the final game, this button will say your name, whatever name that is.
Here.
Let's have you roleplay as Jim to really simulate the full experience of this feature.
Just fail me.
I promise you'll love it.
Okay, here we go.
Let's take a deep breath.
Clear your mind.
Forget whoever you are.
And simply become a person named Jim.
I want you to imagine yourself living as Jim.
Sleeping and waking as Jim.
Falling in love and being heartbroken as Jim.
Seizing all of the world's possibilities as Jim.
And as Jim.
Watching your dreams crumble into dust.
Do you feel it deeply?
Are you really, truly Jim right now?
I think so.
I'm Jim.
If so, then please step forward and press the button.
Jim!
Yes!
You see!
What a thrill!
What a rush!
That was you!
What a thrill!
The button described you.
Do it again.
I think I'm really starting to, like, you know, it's one of those, like, think it till you believe it sort of things, you know, like...
Jim.
It hits even harder the second time.
If this were the only new feature in The Stanley Parable 2, it would still be worth the money.
Let's take a break from the Jim button.
I'm too emotionally drained from all of this personal validation.
Hold on.
I'm just changing the stream title a little bit.
There we go.
Cool.
Jim.
Whoa there, cowboy.
Sometimes a person can be too much Jim.
I'm putting the Jim button away.
No!
Otherwise, soon you'll start to lose all sense of who you actually are.
Jim.
You can't stop me!
You can't deny me!
You can't deny me my identity!
Anyway...
I felt good.
I felt good, you know, when I...
When I died, there were some things that I lost, some memories, you know, but now I feel...
I feel this post-Jim clarity that I just never thought that I would ever, you know, feel.
It's the dead tree.
It's still here.
I suppose I could allow only people named Jim to play the Stanley Parable 2.
True.
That would actually save me the work of finishing this feature.
Don't be lazy, narrator.
Don't be la...
No screenshots, everybody.
Whole new office.
999.
Red is the new...
Is that coming from the game?
Wait, is that from me or...
Jimperms revoked.
New features.
New content.
New ideas.
New updated rate.
Traced more of the same but in a good way, sequel to the...
Okay, I think it's in the game.
Oh my god, that scared me.
The baby!
The button baby!
Button ba...
Baby is all grown...
Button baby!
Cuttin' baby!
Consistent quality with just the right amount of change.
Schwing shaders.
Oh, the bucket!
No screenshots.
Is that?
Oh my god, it's me!
Wow, I'm tall!
I grew like an extra foot or so.
So...
We got collectibles.
Turning me into a U2s.
Oh yeah, Stanley U2s!
Free, new and easy achievement.
Can you find them?
Collect them all.
We all run around gathering up these miniature Stanley figurines.
And what's truly innovative is that there will be no reward for collecting all of them.
I don't want to stifle the intrinsic joy of watching a number go up.
You simply collect all of them and then you move the hell on with your unremarkable life.
How
am I gonna become like that?
Oh!
Yippee!
Get me out of there.
God, it really is the worst when you collect everything in a video game and then they give you a big fancy reward for it.
Absolutely tragic.
So true, so true, so true.
I don't need a reward.
I don't want anything.
Scooty Puff Jr. Thanks for the donation.
$10.
Thank you for the donation.
Oh my god, my brain.
Thank you!
Jump circle.
Oh, we had that, we had that.
This map, free achievement.
Where do we get the achievement at?
Q.
So, what's N?
N is the jump circle.
This is the jump circle, right?
Oh, there it is.
There's a sign for it.
You know what, Stanley?
I actually think the jump circle was a pretty good idea.
I'd like to hang on to that for the sequel.
Oh, this is the 10 that I have left.
Nice.
Free achievement.
Pull the lever, receive your new achievement.
No more steps, it just works.
Now, here's something special.
You remember that broken test achievement that got left in the game on accident?
Yeah.
Well, I'm developing a technology to simply give you the achievement.
Yes.
Wow.
You see, you'll come to this lever, and when you pull it, the achievement will be given to you.
Okay, perhaps I should have clarified.
This is technology that will exist.
Right now, the achievement is still fully broken.
I'm not a wizard, Stanley, but I guarantee it will be fixed in the future.
Come on, narrator.
You're busting my balls here, narrator.
Please.
Gamers, we hear you.
Gamers.
And I promise it will happen.
Rise up, gamers.
I cannot believe this.
What else?
What other exhibits haven't we seen yet?
The bucket?
What's in here?
Okay, I'll be honest.
I haven't yet decided on this one.
What is this?
I think that in the new version, the office could use a bit of decoration, like balloons.
But I've undecided on get well someday and happy 12th birthday.
Which would you go with?
I think I'd get well someday.
Okay.
You know, sometimes when you solicit another person's opinion, it makes you realize that you knew which one you actually really wanted all along.
I hate you, narrator.
Happy 12th birthday, step-niece it is.
This one is stuck.
This one... this one won't even... this one...
Okay.
Oh my god!
Or actually, maybe I should have gone with... no.
No?
I've made my decision.
We're moving on.
The end is never the end is never the end.
Would you wear these?
This t-shirt is the new... is the best new feature.
I saw the new content.
Oh, the bucket!
That's right.
Let's go get our bucket.
That code works?
Wait, what code?
Which one?
I didn't see a code.
Oh, the QR code.
Oh, I don't have my phone on me, you guys.
I don't know where my phone is.
I think I left it somewhere.
I think I left it after when I was cooking.
I'll try it here.
I left it up there.
Everybody else can check it.
There you go.
Go ahead and scan.
The button that says Jim.
It looks so sad.
A common complaint of the Stanley Parable was that it was confusing and paradoxical.
That it engendered a chaotic sense of reckless despair in those who played it.
Nice.
I'm happy to say that after much consideration, I've engineered a clever solution to this fundamental problem with the game.
Okay.
It's the Stanley Parable Reassurance Bucket.
You see, Stanley, anytime you're holding the bucket, a sense of calm and ease will fill your mind and your heart.
It's true.
As long as you hold on to the bucket, the many disorienting contradictions of the Stanley Parable will feel perfectly normal.
And perhaps, even comforting.
You may even come to long for the gentle embrace of jarring cognitive dissonance while the bucket is in your arms.
Bucket.
And to be honest, it's a much more convenient solution for me than actually redesigning the game to be less uncomfortable.
Can you imagine what a pain in the ass that would be?
Yes.
The bucket is the perfect solution.
Give me the bucket.
Come on.
Give it a try.
Wait.
Can I walk here?
Okay.
Why are you laughing?
Can you feel it?
The glow of comfort, even in the face of crushing despair, must already be sweeping through your body.
This is my second cup.
And in fact, can I say that I do believe the bucket lends you an air of charisma as well?
It does.
I think so.
I think that just holding it has made you the slightest bit more attractive as a person.
Do you think I think so?
The benefits of the bucket seem to go on and on, don't they?
Yeah.
All this and more await you in the Stanley Parable 2.
I think so, honestly.
I feel really...
Look, I come walking out and I feel like...
No.
Stop.
Stop it.
Oh, my God.
Just... Oh, my God.
Does anyone give out awards for most enjoyable bucket in a video game?
I don't know.
That really should be an award if it isn't already.
Oh, wait.
It's like I can see this girl over here.
She's like been staring at me.
She's like, I've been looking at you from ever since you walked into the room.
Your bucket is really alluring.
And I'll be like, yeah, my bucket is like, you know, it's pretty cool.
It's, you know, I've been with this bucket for a long time.
Do you want to touch my bucket?
She's like, is it okay?
I mean, I don't want to be, I don't want to be too forward.
But, like, it would be my first time touching someone's bucket before.
And be like, it's okay.
I don't normally let people do this.
But, you know, you can even hold it if you want.
She's like, wow.
And then she takes it and she's like, she's like cradling it like a baby.
And she's just like, gosh.
This just feels really natural.
Like, I just feel, I feel, I feel like I should have met you a long time ago.
And I'm like, you know what?
It doesn't matter.
We can make up for lost time.
Sweet Caroline.
Bah, bah, bah.
Oh, infinite hole.
Okay, I'm not going to lie.
I'm pretty sure this is where my game worked last time.
I think this is where my game froze before.
In the infinite hole.
So, I'm a little scared of going in there.
You cannot fall.
You can fall until the end of time, if you like.
A stunning leap forward for video games as a medium.
Oh, it's so quiet.
Thought I could see it from up there.
Oh, I think I...
Hey, how could I see...
I thought I saw it from up here.
How is that possible?
Am I crazy?
I thought I saw it from here.
Weird.
It calls.
Okay.
Okay, guys.
Oh, the roof lowered.
Oh, okay.
Here we go!
It's a quote from yesterday.
What the fuck?
Isn't it wonderful?
One of my more ingenious concoctions, if I do say so.
Now then, since you've gotten to see the infinite hole, you can press the teleport button.
To pop back up to the top.
And we can continue onward.
Gee, to return to the surface.
But there's an end, right?
Now, I don't mean to be a bummer.
But I do recommend you use the teleport button to go back to the top.
Teleport.
Maybe do it on the sooner rather than later spectrum of things.
What's that sound?
It's like kind of crunchy.
Okay, Stanley.
I don't know quite how to say this tactfully.
But it's possible that I slightly exaggerated the infinite nature of the hole.
Okay.
Is it a very, very deep hole?
To be certain it is.
Wow.
It's an extremely deep hole.
Extremely deep.
I don't want anyone to say that it isn't an astonishingly deep hole.
It is.
Is it infinite?
Well, that sort of depends on your definition of infinity.
From one perspective, the infinite is merely philosophical in nature.
It's more of a...
Ow!
Okay.
Well, good for you.
You found the bottom of the hole.
You found me out, Stanley.
I'm a liar and a cheat.
And you're so clever.
Look, I think the issue here is just that you're unusually fascinated by falling.
What normal person actually wants to fall infinitely?
I figured the hole was as deep as anyone would actually need.
Don't you put this on me.
Maybe you're the problem.
My lunch!
Look, things got a little heated there.
I think we both said some things we didn't mean.
That's me.
Why don't we just put all this behind us and agree to just call the hole most stupid?
The whole thing?
If that works for you, then go ahead and press the teleport button to warp up to the top of the hole and we can move on.
I'll just be up here when you're ready.
It's nothing else, right?
That's it?
Just the two of us, we can make it if we try.
Just the two of us.
just the two of us.
Building castles in the sky...
It's just the two of us.
You and I.
I love holes!
Holes!
Since your debut, you've quickly become tied for my favorite... oh, streamer.
Thank you!
Looking forward to the concert in July.
Thank you so much!
I got shorter!
If you decide you've had enough of the hole, you can hit the teleport button and come join me up above.
I've had enough.
I'm positively thrilled.
I tripped!
How could I have guessed?
You're back in the hole.
If this starts to become a thing where...
I love the eclipse.
I'm starting to become extremely certain that the hole is not only not infinite, but that it's growing steadily less and less infinite.
I suspect that I'm starting to hit the point where it's no longer feasible to call the hole infinitely deep, even by the lax overall standards for accountability and marketing.
Not even a little bit.
What's going on here?
Stanley, I have no explanation for the uncertain nature of the hole's length.
Here, let's try something.
Okay.
Let's pop back up to the top and we'll see if it gets any shorter.
Well, there it is.
Oh!
The shame of my liars...
How is this still appealing to you?
Sorry.
I know you're obsessed with holes, but at this depth, I just can't see this scratching the itch.
Who am I to judge?
You just do whatever it is you're here to do.
It's just like, it feels like a wild instinct to jump into a hole.
Uh-oh.
Oh!
Is the, um, teleport button not working?
Oh, I thought it was my game!
It's not working!
Are you sure?
Yes!
Well, I mean...
I thought...
I really don't have an explanation.
It was working just a moment ago.
Just climb out!
Try it again.
Still nothing?
Well, I suppose...
I can't jump.
I can't do anything.
I suppose there is one thing I can do to fix this.
Okay.
I'm out.
Goodbye, Stanley.
You couldn't bear to play with me in the hole.
And now you'll get more time with it than you could ever have asked for.
It's a win for everyone.
You get to be with the hole.
I get to do literally anything else.
Uh...
Take care, Stanley.
I hope you and the hole have a wonderful rest of it.
Wait!
Oh!
Well, that's a good one.
GG.
Baby.
Oh!
What's going on?
Is someone coming?
Is someone...
GG.
It's not moving, is it?
Are my eyes tricking me?
It looked like it was growing down for a second.
What's happening in my room?
What?
This hole... was made for me.
I changed my perspective.
The bucket!
Germa!
Wait, how do I get back to normal?
Oh, change your perception.
No,
no, I like the...
Oh, this one is...
Oh god.
I like the first one.
What is this?
Using up the space of mind My head's stronger You're no longer Using up the space of mind My head's stronger You're no longer Oh, I love this one.
Using up the space of mind Puppies!
My head's stronger You're no longer Using up the space of mind My head's stronger
Using up the space of mind My head's stronger Okay, please.
My head's stronger Hey!
Hey!
Change your reality My eye!
What is going on?
Oh my god, where's anime?
Yes!
No!
I was waiting for anime Stanley!
Why?
Can I get out?
Toodle pip!
Starting again.
No, we're going back!
That's like my favorite voice effect ever.
Oh my god, my game didn't break!
Let's go!
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
Oh, it's a new construction.
Wait.
But I already have a bucket.
Can I get a second one?
Toodle pip.
I think...
I think that's everything though.
Button that says gym.
Let me go check the map just in...
Oh, that's new!
That door up there!
Can I get to there?
The new door?
That says it's new?
I don't think so.
Let's check out the map.
Make sure I've done everything.
Button that says the name.
Merch.
Settings world champion.
Reassurance bucket.
Office decorations.
Oh yeah, we went in there.
Epilogue.
Collectibles.
Yeah, we went in there.
Epilogue.
What is that?
Where is that?
By five.
Oh, I think it's what I'm looking at up here.
Should I use up the rest of my jumps?
The settings world champion.
I can still do it.
Where was it though?
Over here?
Oh wait, here's a staircase.
Staircase.
Settings world champion.
Over here?
Oh.
Never mind.
Mostly infinite hole.
Free achievement.
Epilogue.
Merch QR code.
I told you I don't have my phone, you guys!
I don't know where my phone is.
I would have to leave and go find it.
But I don't know where it is.
You'll have to get the achievement to get it.
Gotta change every setting in the menu.
Wait, what do you mean?
This?
Oh.
Oh, I think I've probably messed with everything in here.
Oh wait.
Eee.
Slide the sliders all the way.
Oh.
This is so...
God, this is really satisfying to hear though, isn't it?
Oh, this one too.
Oh.
Japanese!
It's just like the most satisfying thing I've ever...
I could listen to this forever.
Sorry, I know I'm not talking.
It's because it just sounds so good.
I don't think I changed anything.
So yeah.
Delete the save data.
Do I have to do all the resolutions and everything?
Oh, this just sounds so good.
It's just...
It just really hits in a good way.
Hold on.
Turn it up some.
FLV to 100?
I did that, didn't I?
Oh.
Oh, thank you.
There we go.
God.
Hey, let me in.
I'm the setting...
Oh, wait.
Of the...
Of the settings world...
Aha!
I can see you've gotten the settings world champion achievement.
Well done.
You've experienced every setting.
Traveled to all corners of the settings menu.
There's nothing you haven't seen.
So, just for you, in the Stanley Parable 2, I'm including an entirely new setting.
Something called Bumpscocity.
Bumpscocity.
What exactly is Bumpscocity?
Yeah.
Well, I haven't quite figured that part out yet, but I just know that you'll be able to adjust it... Well, the subtitles are gone.
...on some sort of slider.
And... Sorry.
But...
...that it'll be available from the settings menu.
There you go.
Sorry.
Bye-bye.
We'll sort the rest of the details out later.
I hope you're looking forward to trying out every level of Bumpscocity in the Stanley Parable 2.
Bumpscocity.
I'm the champion of setting all the sliders to all the possible numbers.
Please enjoy this room.
This is your room.
It was made just for you.
Thank you!
Okay.
Now I think we can leave.
Let's get out of here.
Bump those...
Oh, wait.
Do I actually have a new setting?
Bumpscocity?
Oh, I'm back in here.
Oh!
Bumpscocity!
A thousand.
What did it do?
Bump...
I haven't...
It didn't do anything!
Adjust the Bumpscocity.
It's probably so big that it like...
...that it like...
looped around.
You know what I'm saying?
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
Oh my god!
Whoa, whoa!
I'm feeling it!
Oh!
Oh my god!
Whoa, whoa!
Hold on, I have to...
Okay, I know this is like a new feature.
So it's probably like, you know...
not exactly like...
Okay, that's so much more manageable.
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
Try bump...
Whoa!
Bumpscocity!
I had to really... yeah, it was like a really...
really intense.
I shouldn't have... I should have just worked...
I think this is a type of setting that like...
not everyone can handle.
Like, I can handle it because...
you know, I'm like... better than you.
But I don't think anybody else...
It's like... it takes a really, really, really like... high IQ...
like really, really like specific type of like awesome person to be able to handle it.
You know what I'm saying?
So like...
If you're playing this and you get any... I don't think... I don't expect you guys to get the bumpscocity...
you know... like a slider because it's like pretty... it's like only real gamers can get it.
And so I don't really know if you guys are capable of doing that.
But if you do, if you just happen to get lucky and like maybe like accidentally stumble upon it...
you know...
I would recommend maybe you start at like a 1 and then just kind of like work your way up.
Because for me, I can go from like a thousand and like it's a little hard to adjust but like I'm fine.
For you, I think you might actually be crushed into like into like little tiny...
your little tiny brain would be like you know what I mean?
So...
just don't... don't worry about it.
Mint is better than me confirmed.
No!
Epilogue.
Oh!
An epilogue would be fun, wouldn't it, Stanley?
Yes.
It would go at the end of the...
Why are you guys clowning me?
We'll figure that out later.
That's it?
That's all the epilogue was for?
Taste the sequel.
That was it?
Two!
I like that guy.
Okay.
Okie dokie.
I think that's the exit.
Guys, I'm fine.
It ended.
Do you guys mind if I actually go to the bathroom real quick?
Gotta go to the little ghost's room.
Real fast.
I had tea and bubble tea.
Should I finish up all my jumps too?
I wonder.
Oh wait.
Oh, this is how I get out.
Grab your phone too.
Okay, I'll go look for it if I don't find it really fast.
Then I'm gonna give up.
Okay?
Because I lose my phone all the time.
I don't think you guys realize.
Okay.
I'll be right back.
Let me make a little note that says she's gone to the bathroom.
Gone to the bathroom.
Okay, I'll be right back.
I'm back.
Sorry.
Sorry it took so long.
Oh.
Oh my god.
I had to strip off my phone.
I found my phone.
Okay.
Alright.
I guess since so many people asked, I'll go do the QR code.
I'll go do the QR code.
People are so passionate about QR codes, I guess.
Oh, and my jumps.
Let's finish my jumps.
Welcome home!
Welcome home.
Capture wording, huh?
Emily!
Hello.
Randall, thanks for the five gifted.
Okay, let me scan this with my phone.
Oh my god.
StanleyParable2.com StanleyParable2.com Welcome to the official site of The Stanley Parable 2.
A sequel, huh?
Oh, this is direct YouTube link.
Should I play this on stream?
Hold on.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, it's unlisted even.
Wow.
Okay, one second.
Let me pull it up.
Let me...
New table.
New window.
YouTube.
Oh, no.
It didn't show up in my history.
Why not?
Oh, because...
Oh, shoot.
How do I open it in the app?
Wait.
Open in the app.
There we go.
Okay.
Now I should show up in my history.
There we go.
Oh no, no, no...
One second, one second, one second...
One second, one second, one second, one second...
Uuuh...
Studio Mode
Window Capture Crop, crop, crop, crop...
Crop, crop, crop, crop...
Crop, Crop, Crop.
Okay.
Ta-da!
Okie-dokie.
Alright.
Watch along!
Timmy!
Wow.
Breakfast of Champions.
Lunch!
Wow.
Why isn't Timmy responding?
So true.
Oh.
I don't want to look like that!
I need to stop thinking right now.
Good thing I never thought.
Automobile.
Wow.
How long is this?
No!
Wait!
This is 10 minutes, you guys!
This is so long!
This is 10 minutes!
Hahah.
Times two, Spree.
Five shirts?!
Wow!
Get with the times, Becky.
What?
You know what?
I'll be honest.
I don't know if it's actually getting a sequel.
Is it actually...
Is it actually getting a sequel?
Because...
I can't tell anymore.
It doesn't have enough of the transatlantic accent.
You know what I mean?
To match the...
The vibes of this.
Oh, it isn't.
Okay.
This is the sequel.
You're right.
Yeah, Timmy.
This is why the Stanley Parable 2 will be perfect for you.
It's as manly as video games can get.
And if you don't believe me, let's look at the burly hunk of a man who's responsible for the game.
Here he is, hard at work.
Really?
His name is Gregory Apec.
And he's the cutting picture of royal masculinity.
Gregory is what we call the ideas guy.
And he has the most important role on the team.
The ideas guy tirelessly comes up with interesting ideas.
And then hands them off to the rest of the developers for the relatively simple job of turning those concepts into reality.
I'm an ideas guy.
I don't know how to do anything.
He's the one who picked up the phone and declared, Someone ought to make a sequel to the Stanley Parable.
Good work, Gregory.
Go ahead and take the rest of the day off.
With the hard part out of the way, work on the game can now begin.
Stanley Parable 2 is coming out soon.
Just a month after Minecraft 2.
What makes a sequel in the first place?
Well, it's simple.
Sequels are an opportunity to correct the mistakes of their predecessors.
We've all made mistakes.
And we've all caused harm to someone we love in order to cover up our mistakes.
When developing this particular sequel, it's important to start by thinking, What mistakes did the original Stanley Parable make?
Well, first off, most of the pornography in the original game was stolen or pirated.
And it's time we paid the licensing fees fair and square.
Second, the Stanley Parable was catastrophic for this man named Leroy, whose personal information including home address, social security number, and bank information were all displayed prominently in multiple locations throughout the game.
Although Leroy's money and identity were stolen, the fact remains that his personal information was the emotional core of the game and absolutely vital to a nuanced understanding of the story.
As reparation for the harm we caused him, the sequel will contain a brief and insincere apology to Leroy dug deep within the game where it will be difficult to find.
Finally, the Stanley Parable made the mistake of leaking too many government secrets about the nature of the Time Wars.
The Time Wars?
Without these intricate details of specific military tactics, the story is likely to make very little sense.
There's war in this game?
But we decided to remove them from the sequel in the interest of helping the state's efforts.
We'll get to you yet, Time Dracula.
Dracula?
We're going to set about constructing the Stanley Parable 2.
Game development is a difficult and complex art, one which can only be fully understood by this race of hyper-intelligent child soldiers The children soldiers!
Yippee!
They begin by studying the original Stanley Parable.
Here it is in its raw, untouched form.
They're eating gunpowder!
A specimen of technological perfection.
Time to exploit it for profit.
Let's go!
We begin by adding jokes.
The Stanley Parable was most widely known for its stark lack, lack of humor, bucking all conventional industry wisdom.
It was a bold artist's statement that its developers stood firmly behind.
But in 2022, it's impossible to reach even a single consumer of video games without jokes of some kind.
So very well, jokes it'll be.
Woo!
We're getting jokes!
Uh-oh, my YouTube broke.
Hold on, you guys.
Oh gosh.
I can't re-chat.
I'm sorry.
Creating jobs for hundreds of machine operators, and producing 30,000 tons of pollutant chemical byproduct, which will be pumped directly into local lakes, rivers, and beautiful nature reserves like these all over the country.
Ah, screw the environment!
Another common complaint of the Stanley Parable is that there wasn't enough gameplay.
And so for the sequel, its developers have gone to great lengths to fix this problem.
Here we can see gameplay being printed onto sheets.
Every video game contains as many as a thousand sheets of gameplay.
That's a lot of gameplay.
The largest games ever made contain close to 1,500.
On mobile devices, the gameplay sheets have to be printed smaller.
For the Stanley Parable 2, as many as 35 new gameplay sheets are being printed, each of which must be delicately massaged by the hands of a child before being added into the game.
This man is stealing gameplay sheets from the factory, which he likely intends to use for a personal project he's been developing in his spare time.
Kill him!
Stoning?
Let's check on Gregory real quick.
Ha!
Still recovering from a hard day's work.
Don't you move a muscle.
Good job, Gregory.
It's time to blackmail the press.
In a competitive market, blackmailing your local journalist can be one of the most effective methods of creating word-of-mouth buzz for your sequel.
In fact, blackmail is the currency of social progress.
From your neighborhood grocer, to the teacher at your school, to the man who helps you steal, HBO, everyone responds to blackmail.
And if you've never done it before, it's easy to practice at home on your friends and family.
Simply follow the instructional pamphlet that your teacher hands out after the end of the show.
And finally, there's one last tool at our disposal for making the sequel feel fresh and exciting, and that's packaging the game with collector's edition merchandise.
If you order The Stanley Parable 2, you'll receive this cow's egg, a single egg will produce over a thousand cows, which are, of course, the sequel to Pigs.
And there you have it.
Everything there is to know about producing The Stanley Parable 2.
Of course, you may know that there is also a game titled The Stanley Parable Ultra Deluxe.
So which game is the true sequel to The Stanley Parable?
Gregory looks so confused.
Oh, sorry, Billy.
One which the child soldiers have been working round the clock to come up with an answer to.
Come on!
Feed them more gum powder!
And after many weeks of diligent research, the conclusion they've reached is, who gives a shit?
All that matters is that it's more content for you to cram down your insatiable gullet.
You don't want thoughtful and nuanced answers to complex questions, Billy.
I'm eating all this content.
You just want to eat bubble gum and cheated hopscotch.
How do you cheat at hopscotch?
Do your civic duty and bully your parents into buying you every version of The Stanley Parable 2 on every platform.
I already do that with Metal Gear Solid.
Tell your friends to bully their parents as well.
And I bully other people to play Metal Gear.
It's through community efforts like these that the world comes together in harmony and connection.
And it's only through this connection that we'll defeat time Dracula once and for all.
Don't let the time-traveling vampires win.
Buy The Stanley Parable 2 and pledge to support all sequels.
For today, tomorrow, and into the great, unknowable beyond.
The end.
Nice.
Well, that was fun.
Oh, wait!
Hold on.
There was one more thing.
There was one more thing at the very end!
Oh, no!
One second.
Billy!
In memoriam of Billy!
1953.
1956.
Oh, God!
Billy!
Oh, no, no!
Was that everything, though?
Yeah, okay.
Okay, I'm continuing the game, everybody.
I think we can actually finally exit.
I think we can actually finally leave.
Curse you, time Dracula.
Curse you!
Okay.
This is all new for me now.
Actually, I've never even watched that.
I think I was going to watch it before, and I forgot.
So now...
Oh!
Have you seen everything you wanted to?
Yeah.
Ready to move on now?
Mint Phantom is my favorite React content beat-em-er.
Now!
Oh.
Whoa.
New mugs!
Why does he look so scary?
It's like, uh...
What's that?
What's that game?
Layers of Stanley.
Oh!
Please no screenshots, everybody!
Oh, what's this?
So, Stanley.
What do you think?
Do you like all of the new features?
I really do!
Yes, I know it's not exactly clear yet how exactly these features will come together as one single coherent video game.
I can feel it in my soul.
Can I hear you?
It's going to work.
There's definitely a good game in there somewhere.
Say, let's do an experiment.
Okay.
I'll arrange these new features together, and we'll see whether or not it coheres into a meaningful gameplay experience.
No screenshots!
Are you ready?
Yes.
Here it is.
I give you...
The Stanley Parable 2.
Oh!
Oh.
Oh...
Um.
Well, um...
I mean, there's potential here, right?
It's sort of...
Okay, never mind.
Hold on.
Let me do a different arrangement.
Okay, yes.
Yes!
This is much better.
I feel like I could've done this.
I'm Jim.
Oh, my gosh, Jim!
Here we go.
Uh...
No...
Who am I kidding, Stanley?
The Jump Circle.
Whoa!
This isn't a coherent video game at all.
It's a lot of games.
Hmm...
Oh!
Okay.
Tastefully, of course, of course.
Ladies and gentlemen, welcome back.
Thank you!
Why can't it be so sad in there?
Oooh!
Stanley Parable 2!
Okay.
Okay, I'm excited.
I'm closing my eyes.
Oh!
The Stan...
Oooh!
P.T.?
The Stanley Parable 2.
Wow!
It's kinda creepy!
Quit the desktop.
I guess we gotta begin the game, you guys.
Woah!
Click to skip.
This is the story of a man named Stanley.
Stanley worked for a company in a big building where he was employee number 427.
Employee number 427's job was simple.
He sat at his desk in room 427 and he pushed buttons on a keyboard.
Orders came to him through a monitor...
Oh my gosh, wait.
Our bucket?
Where's the bucket?
How long to push them?
And in what order?
Yeah, we got the balloons and everything.
This is what employee 427 did every day of every month of every year.
Although others might have considered it sorely.
Stanley relished every moment that the boys came in.
But though he had been made exactly for this job, Stanley was happy.
He was happy.
And then one day, something very peculiar happened.
Something that would forever change Stanley.
Something he would never quite forget.
He had been at his desk for nearly an hour.
When he realized that not one single order had arrived on the monitor for him to follow.
The balloons!
No, I wanted the other balloons.
I wanted the other ones.
Never in all his years at the company had this happened.
This complete isolation.
Something was very clearly wrong.
Shocked.
Frozen solid.
Stanley found himself unable to move for the longest time.
But as he came to his wits and regained his senses, he got up from his desk and stepped out of his office.
I hope you get well eventually, babe.
Happy 12th birthday, babe.
I like how you guys both said the opposite things at the same time.
Okay, here we go, I guess.
All of his co-workers were gone.
What could it mean?
Stanley decided to go to the meeting room.
Perhaps he had simply missed a memo.
Happy 12th birthday, step-niece!
My favorite step-niece in the world.
Stanley picked up the bucket.
We got a bucket.
Stanley clutched the bucket tightly to his chest and entered the door on his left.
What have I done?
I mean, I know I like the bucket.
I know the bucket, like, gives me that... that...
What should I do, bucket?
What should I do?
Okay.
This was not the correct way to the meeting room.
But Stanley had felt the bucket calling to him.
Telling him that the employee lounge was simply the place to be.
Simply the place to be.
And here it was.
Had the bucket turned out to be correct?
Yes!
Was this better than the meeting room?
Yes, Stanley thought to himself.
Yes, perhaps it truly was.
Perhaps it truly was.
How insightful the bucket turned out to be.
Oh my god, everything is re-dubbed with the bucket.
The bucket's so awesome.
Never mind.
The bucket was wrong.
Uh, never.
Not at all.
Stanley took the door on his left to go back to the meeting room.
What does this way go to?
Oh, this one is, uh...
Yeah, where I fell before.
What was this way again?
Oh!
And this way...
Oh, we went downstairs.
Okay.
Yeah, the bucket's never wrong.
Kinda wanna ride it, though.
No, said the bucket.
No!
Don't go to the meeting room.
Go somewhere else.
A cargo lift, yes.
Go there.
Go to the cargo lift.
No, don't go to the meeting room.
Good, said the bucket.
Now ride the lift all the way to the top.
There's something up there I need you to do.
Oh my god, there's even a balloon at the top.
Well, there's several.
It should have alarmed him, of course, because buckets can't talk.
But Stanley chose not to think about this obvious fact.
We're gonna go.
Because the bucket...
And he unthinkingly did whatever the bucket asked.
Okay, sounds good.
No.
In here, said the bucket.
Go into this dark room over here.
Over here?
Stanley once again obeyed blindly.
This room's not very dark.
This room's pretty bright, actually.
Oh!
Oh.
Are you sure, bucket?
Okay.
Now pick up the phone, said the bucket.
Pick up the phone, and it will take us back home, where we can go about life together.
Really?
Thanks for the five gift items you...
Oh, customer, thank you!
This is the sad story of a man named Stanley and his bucket.
Where's my bucket?
Once upon a time, I gave Stanley a bucket because I thought he was lonely and could use a friend.
And then, very distressingly, he began to believe the bucket could speak to him.
Is this my house?
Oh my god, Stanley lives in an Ikea, like, uh, setup.
There's the bucket!
Hello, Stanley, it's me.
Oh.
Hello, Stanley, it's me, your bucket.
Press U to take me to walk with...
Walk with you.
Oh.
The Stanley Parable Reassurance Bucket was merely meant to provide the comforting glow of companionship.
Oh my gosh, thank you so much for that, buddy.
Take care.
Bye.
Thank you.
Oh, here it is.
Press O to take me back home with you.
Lately, I've been concerned about him.
Wouldn't you be concerned as well?
To see him delusional like this, obsessing over an inanimate metal object?
I want to say something to him, but I don't know how I can convince him.
Where's my bucket?
I don't know if he'll listen to me.
Thought I lost him for a second.
Oh.
Okay.
Press J to go back to work.
I'll try anyway.
Stanley, can you hear me?
Bucket.
Can you hear me, bucket?
It can't think.
Bucket.
Where are you?
Oh, thank you.
All it would ever truly do for you is effectively transfer a liquid from one location to a different location.
I don't hear anybody else.
I only hear the bucket.
That's it.
It doesn't do anything else.
Don't listen to the loud man.
Press R for us to go back home.
Okay.
Oh.
You see, he's not listening.
He's still taking orders from the bucket.
Bucket.
You know, once upon a time...
...it was me he took orders from.
Bucket.
Where are you, bucket?
Me he trusted and listened to.
Now all he cares about is his awful bucket.
Where's the bucket?
Where's my bucket?
Narrator.
Oh, here.
Press O to ignore anyone in your life except for me.
Well, guys.
That's a lot of O's.
Thank you.
It's sad.
I suppose he doesn't need me anymore.
From now on, he's just going to cling to this bucket.
This cold, empty bucket.
This sort of shiny bucket.
Well, I'll give it this.
The bucket does have a nice shine to it.
Yeah, it does.
You believe I'm real, don't you, Stanley?
Press H to go back home.
Yes, I suppose on closer inspection that it doesn't quite look like your average hardware store bucket.
It's just a little more, um...
What am I trying to say?
Sturdier.
More capable of transporting liquid.
Yeah.
See?
Like it would be better at moving an amount of water from one room to another.
Press R to relive the scene.
Same day with me, over and over.
Oh my God, what am I saying?
Better at carrying water from room to room.
It's a bucket.
It's literally just a bucket.
Why do I feel some need to point out the ways in which it's so much more than just a regular bucket?
Press I to go home, to work to home, to work to home.
Oh no.
I'm...
I'm having feelings.
For the bucket.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
What's going on?
Why do I want to be with the bucket?
Hear what the bucket has to say.
Do anything it asks.
What's wrong with me?
I don't understand.
Perhaps...
Perhaps if I had the bucket, this would be less confusing.
Yes.
The bucket could tell me what to do in this troublesome situation.
Is the bucket waiting for me on the bed?
B-bucket.
I mean...
This is so nice.
I didn't...
You know...
I thought you would be too tired after such a long day.
But you...
Even...
Even despite that, you put all of this together for me?
Bucket.
I mean...
Wow.
It's just so beautiful.
It's just...
No bucket.
Stanley, give me the bucket.
Give it to me.
Give me the bucket, Stanley.
I need it.
No!
Give it to me now.
Give it or I'll...
No!
Close your eyes.
Go
back to work, Stanley.
Go back to work, Stanley.
Bucket?
All of his co-workers were gone.
What could it mean?
Bucket!
Stanley decided to go to the meeting room.
Perhaps he had simply missed a memo.
Stanley lifted the bucket into his arms.
And a wave of comfort rushed over him.
Oh!
That was...
Men's Phantom, parasocial for a bucket.
Trust the bucket.
Believe in the bucket.
That was...
Such a fun ending.
That was so funny.
I loved that.
Oh, wait.
Oh!
It got the second input!
How is that in there?
I think though...
I think I might...
Call it quits here.
Buckets on my doko.
I wish there was a way...
Oh!
Sequel has now published.
Pause.
Wait, this is so crazy!
I wish there was a way to know how many endings you had left.
You know what I mean?
That ending was fantastic.
I think that was a good one to end on.
I think.
I think so.
Send the bucket to space.
Achieve... Oh, I guess an achievement.
Yeah, probably.
Let me see.
Oh, I've unlocked only 4 out of 11?
Wait, view my achievements.
Uh, quit the game and start it again.
Wait.
Oh, some of these... what is it?
A, A, A, A, A, A, A, A...
Oh, the test achievement!
Please ignore!
Speedrun, complete the Stanley Parable in under 4 minutes.
Don't play the Stanley Parable for 10 years.
It doesn't have a list of the achievements.
Why so blushy?
Oh, sorry.
Just because I was holding on to the bucket, you know?
Bucket will last forever.
Long live the bucket!
Thanks for a month!
Thank you!
But...
Yeah.
Let me see.
But yeah, there is one that says don't play the Stanley Parable for 10 years.
And then, play the Stanley Parable for the entire duration of a Tuesday.
Wait, is that starting at like 12 AM?
2...
2, 11, 59 PM?
This is a great...
Was this great to have on a birthday Thanksgiving?
Stuffed Shark!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Stuffed.
Sometimes I say, stupid shark.
Sorry for calling you.
Stupid.
Happy birthday!
Thank you for the super chat.
But yeah.
This was a lot of fun.
It was good seeing things that I've never seen before.
And remembering things that I have seen before.
Sometimes.
And then also...
My game not breaking.
So I could do the bucket, you know?
Okay.
I should play the bucket, too.
But...
I think...
I don't know.
How many endings are there even?
Be wary of the time vampires.
Yeah.
Right?
Oh, my gosh.
Five clicks?
No.
I'm going to do 10 clicks.
I'm going to do 11 clicks.
I'm going to be...
I'm going to do 50 clicks.
I don't even know what you're talking about.
And you keep spamming five clicks.
Why do I feel like I'm in the ice monkey all over the place?
Thank you for the bucket stream.
Just wanted to say, even if you didn't win your match with Fillion last night was fantastic.
Even though I teleported and then I...
Even though I teleported and then...
And then I...
20 plus endings and the bucket doubles it?
No way.
Oh my god, stupid shark!
Thank you for the 20, you have to thank you!
0, 0, 0, ice monkey.
5 click, 5 click, 5 click, ice monkey.
I teleported behind her and it didn't even make a difference.
SMH.
SMH!
But it's okay, I beat Matara and that's all that really mattered.
Plus, I think I would have felt really bad if I had made it to the finals because...
I was kind of a joke entry, so...
I was kind of a joke entry, so... you know.
But it was a lot of fun.
Actually...
I'm going to move us over to the maid cafe.
Give me a second.
First off, I gotta change.
I'm not naked, I'm just...
Anyway...
Hold on, I'm getting dressed.
Hold on.
Hold on, I'm getting dressed!
Let me exit out of the game too.
Quit to menu.
Quit to desktop.
Let's put on something chill.
Some music, just for a little bit.
Because I have some stuff I need to take care of.
Uh...
Ptptptp.
Sorry, hold on.
There we go.
Okey dokey.
I'm all changed!
Oh, my arms.
My arms.
There we go.
All better.
Talk strings!
Thanks for the vibe gifted!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
The wisp singing karaoke is so cute.
I know, right?
Show them chicken wings!
Is this what you wanted?
Is this what you like?
Those two are still cooking...
It's Memorial Day!
Yay!
Of course they're having a barbecue.
Gosh, duh.
She's gonna take off.
Oh, that was so fun!
Oh my gosh.
Maybe I'll do a part two and get some other of the endings.
But it's like... a little daunting, I feel, to get to first... how much is in the game.
But I'm really happy that I could at least get the bucket.
At least the bucket ending was so fun.
I really liked that one.
Ducky, thanks for the vibe gift and thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
What was your favorite bit?
Maybe the bucket.
I know it's like the most recent one, but...
Synapse, thanks for the super chat!
Marsha, thanks for the super chat!
But I know it was like... maybe because it was like the... it felt newer.
But I also really liked the... because my game broke before in the hole.
I never got to see like all the special things that went on with it, so...
That was really fun too.
And the skip button.
The skip button one really makes you just kinda...
Has like a good... I don't want... it's not a feels good.
But it's like a good...
It makes you feel something, you know what I mean?
Makes you... makes you feel.
Oh, the bottom of the mind control room song!
Yes!
That was so good!
Oh my gosh, I was so happy we got that one.
It was really awesome.
It's very somber.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But...
It's crazy how much replayability this game has, you know?
So, this week will be a bit of a short week.
I'll be streaming... I'll have a...
I have to still figure out what I'm streaming.
Because I'll be going to Off-Kai for this weekend.
And then from Off-Kai...
Matara and I will be going to...
To...
To Japan!
So...
While we're there, we're kind of gonna be like...
Streaming every other day.
So she'll stream one day and I'll stream...
The next day.
And so on and so forth.
So...
Probably won't have a schedule for that.
So I really apologize.
It's been kind of like...
Schedulist.
Even...
Last week and this week and...
I didn't mean to not have a schedule last week.
I think...
I've kind of mentioned it.
Well, no.
I mentioned... I think I've mentioned it on the Patreon thing.
It was funny because I saw... I would see some comments...
Being like...
I wonder if...
If Mint is keeping her schedule...
A secret because...
Of WrestleTuber, you know?
Because she's...
She doesn't want to spoil that she's gonna be a guest.
And I'll be honest...
Uh...
That was not the case.
I...
I just...
I just didn't put one out.
I just didn't want to put one out because I was...
Indecisive about what I wanted to do.
My brain has been kind of all over the place because I'm like...
Trying to figure out...
How do I...
Get ready for...
For my trips and...
And...
Planning other stuff and...
Contacting...
Sending emails and...
It's been a little...
It's been a little bit overwhelming.
But...
Thinking Mint is more clever than we thought.
No, actually...
The...
The WrestleTuber was pretty last minute.
But...
I'm really glad that I could participate.
Last night...
Doki and I...
We were up...
I was up until like...
Almost 4 a.m.
Uh...
Talking with her.
We were catching up.
So...
Um...
I was really...
Really glad.
I was really happy.
Um...
Because...
I was...
Um...
I don't want to say too much about it.
But I was like kind of nervous about reaching out.
Um...
I mostly...
Uh...
I mostly kept my distance...
For...
A while because I...
Didn't want to make her uncomfortable.
But...
Um...
I...
Ultimately...
I'm glad that I did.
So...
Um...
Yeah...
I had a lot of fun...
For WrestleTuber.
Um...
You have no idea how well the...
Oh...
The shippers are eating this week.
Uh...
I'm happy...
For you...
Um...
I'm happy...
For you...
For you...?
But yeah...
Um...
They are eating good.
I'll be honest.
I've seen fan art.
There's been a lot of fan art.
So...
So thank you guys.
Um...
Mmm, what is bro yapping about?
And even Matara joining, hers was like super last minute too, so...
And you know, it was funny.
She sent me a couple of voice lines.
I was like, can you send me some stuff and then I'll send it over to her and to Doki and she can send it to her editor and this and that.
Matara was funny AF.
I know!
I wish... I hope next time she can participate in person if she wants to.
But I thought it was really funny that... even I felt bad.
I was like, you're on vacation, sorry.
But the editor cooked so much.
In such a short amount of time they did it.
It was so great.
We're happy for the both of you.
Thanks for sticking around.
Thank you!
Thank you.
I can't tell you... I can't tell you guys how much it like...
I... how much I...
What's the word?
Like went back and forth.
How much I was just like... I don't want to make her uncomfortable but...
I wanna... I was like I miss my friend.
So... and it was... it was something that was really like eating at me for a while.
And I was just like, I don't know.
I don't know how she feels about me anymore.
So...
Yeah.
But I'm glad it worked out.
Because the last thing I would want to do is make, you know, anybody feel uncomfortable.
So...
But we... we...
The first night that we like...
Caught up a little bit.
I was... I was up so late.
We were just like talking and catching up.
And...
Last night, the same thing too.
Afterwards, I was just like...
I was like, oh, she's probably so tired.
She probably doesn't want to like hang out too much.
But...
But then I was like...
I was like, girl, you need to go get some water.
So...
The geography argument.
I'm sure she appreciated it.
It was such a fun event.
It was great to see you guys stream together.
Yeah.
And then...
Afterwards, like some of the other participants messaged me as well.
And I was really happy about that.
So...
Maybe I can...
Make more friends with people.
Yeah.
But...
Yippee.
I'm resting...
Yeah.
She was so sweet.
After the first day...
She added me in the...
Like in the server that we were in for the event.
She was like...
She was like, it was nice talking with you finally.
Even though it was like in this environment.
Canonically, who was the security guard you killed?
What do you mean canonically?
Exactly.
I killed several people.
I killed... I killed... I killed... I killed the... I killed people.
People were happy to see you around?
Who saw that coming?
Everyone else.
What do you mean?
Aren't you a member of Fillion's pirate crew now?
I am!
I am, I am.
I remember you promised someone a collab after finishing Ghost Trick.
I know, I know.
I'm kind of... I have a lot...
Basically, once I get back from Japan...
I plan on...
Really...
Hitting the ground running.
I've been trying to plan stuff for my anniversary.
My not four year anniversary.
My one year anniversary.
I've been trying to plan stuff for that.
I've been trying to plan stuff for...
For my...
Maybe I shouldn't say that.
People love you, you dorkoid.
What does that mean?
My anniversary?
Oh my god.
Wait!
Thank you for the akasoba!
It was so great to see you at WrestleTember.
I'm really glad.
You and Doki had a good time catching up.
Thank you!
What truly made me smile is how you two didn't seem to miss a beat.
Immediately into the half laughing, half screaming.
I guess that's just...
I don't know.
I guess...
I don't know how to say.
Maybe it is our destiny to always...
Or to act that way.
Maybe I felt compelled even though I have never...
Met her before.
But yeah.
I know it's shocking but so many people love...
Adore...
And support you.
You are amazing.
I got home from Paname.
I saw a lot of fan words of you.
See you at Afkai hopefully!
See you!
I've been told dorkoid is the yellow one.
Regardless.
We love you, Mito.
What I mean by that is we love you.
Stop!
Dorkoid.
Dorkoid!
But...
I love the part when Doki...
Accidentally called herself small brain and you were like...
Yep.
She's a bird after all.
You know?
I think You-san's entrance was so...
I didn't even know that was gonna happen.
So...
I didn't...
That was my first time seeing that, too.
So...
It was really... really something.
Will you let us know when you get in the robot at Ofukai?
I didn't get a meet and greet but still want to meet you.
I think that's still being planned.
But once I know anything, I know it's like kind of last minute.
Because Ofukai is this weekend!
Oh my gosh!
Ofukai is this weekend, you guys!
But I will let you guys know as soon as I know.
Because I don't know what.
Thanks for being at the truck event.
Thank you!
Yeah, the truck event was really fun too.
Everybody was super duper hype.
And...
There were so many people.
I was really shocked.
Actually, right before I went on, I was like messaging my friend.
Because she was there.
And I was like...
They kind of sandwiched me between two DJs.
I'm going to bring the mood down so much.
Because I'm like not a DJ.
It's not like continuous music.
Like I'm going to be singing.
And it's going to be weird.
And she was like...
No, it will be fine.
You'll just...
You'll have a lot of fun.
So I was really, really actually quite nervous about it.
And...
Possible block game adventure collab.
With who?
Doki?
Maybe.
I don't really know how I can...
How I can feel more proud.
Thank you for existing the way you are.
But don't stop.
Thank you.
I'm so happy you chose to reach out.
You two interacting and speak content.
And she could use a friend who can call her out on her shit.
Yeah.
She calls me out.
We call out each other.
I feel...
I actually think I get dumber around her.
I actually think I'm like...
I'm physically stupid.
More stupid when she's around.
Our September was awesome.
It's so great to hear you.
Doki had time outside of the event to hang.
Thanks for sharing.
It means a lot to us parasocial weirdos.
We love you guys.
You deserve the best.
It's been...
Thank you.
Brain cell sharing is real.
Oh my gosh.
Rice Nat and Orca right next to each other.
Please stop.
Stop.
What was I going to say though?
Um...
I can't help what I see.
I can't help what pops up on my Twitter.
You know?
I can't help it.
Good to see you at the truck.
Thank you.
But yeah.
So I was really nervous for the truck.
And then in the end, everybody was...
The energy was so there.
People were lifting.
There was Kujaku.
There was...
Sorry.
There was so much going on.
It was a lot, a lot of fun.
And people...
There were people on top of cars.
On top of trucks watching.
We love Anikura.
Anikura Saiko!
Your sweater has been so good.
Oh, they built a fire pit out of glow sticks.
Yeah.
If anybody went to...
To...
See me.
And I've never been to Anikura...
I hope that you got a little bit of a taste of why I love idols so much and idols and like, you know, doing calls and just stuff like that like it's just such a fun energy that that truly only can be felt in that kind of that kind of place.
Oh, so fun though.
I felt so happy.
I just felt so fulfilled on on on Saturday.
It was honestly just this weekend.
This past weekend.
I felt so fulfilled.
I felt really I probably felt the happiest I have in in in quite a while.
So I'm really happy.
I wish I could have gone to the truck event even though it was a drive away, but WrestleTuber was wild.
Glad you had fun and hope you have fun in JP too.
Thank you, Jay.
Thank you for the welcome.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
There's still things that I'm trying to catch up on.
Some things I feel like I still feel.
I still feel really nervous about.
Uncertain, I guess maybe is a better word because I feel sort of like how does how do I say this?
How do I say this without being weird?
Everything's weird, though.
I feel I think basically I don't know how to say it.
Sorry, I'm not very articulate.
Step by step.
I guess that's mainly it.
I'm just trying to take things step by step, but I'm trying not to lose out.
I'm trying not to be so passive that I lose out on opportunities.
It's kind of it's hard.
It's hard.
It's hard going from.
Going from a place that took care of everything for you.
To having to do everything on my own and, you know, not knowing at all what to do or how to do anything.
Being by myself.
So.
Oh.
Sorry.
I'm biting my tongue a little bit here, but it's a big adjustment.
I bet.
Yeah.
So.
Hmm.
But hopefully, hopefully I can get things moving, especially once I get back from Japan.
Hopefully I can get things moving forward.
And, you know, moving forward means.
Not only just more opportunities for me, but then also more things for you guys as well.
Because.
Thank you for not becoming a grocer.
Stop.
Why do you guys always bring up that?
Why do you guys always bring that up?
Oh, my gosh.
We believe in you.
Thank you.
Yeah.
It's okay to be weird.
Weirdroid.
What does that mean?
Oh.
But.
It's because it's so upsetting you even thought about it.
It's surreal to think it was a possibility.
Because it's such a shocking thing to hear.
What?
What do you mean?
Oh, my gosh.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
I'd like that.
Wait.
Like what?
Me to become a grocer?
Yeah.
This is the Akasupa telling me to quit?
If you became a grocer, I would buy food every day.
Stop.
I would just be...
I would just be back as a normal ghost.
You know?
Don't worry.
I'd avoid the self-checkout for you.
No.
Oh.
That's so sweet.
Yeah, but...
I don't know.
Maybe I'll...
I was gonna say maybe I'll do it in my free time, but I don't have much free time anymore, really.
Hmm.
Kater, thanks for the super chat.
You're weird, so don't mind being weird.
You know what I call my cat?
When he is bored, I call him Kater.
I don't know why I say it like that.
You know when you talk to animals and like your vocabulary breaks?
It's like when you talk to babies.
Why sell the mint when you can be the mint?
Johnny, thank you for the 10 gifted!
Thank you so much!
Does Pies ever act weird?
Oh, all the time.
She is also weird though.
She is so weird.
Imagine if your idol was she retired and you bumped into her at the register of your local 7-Eleven.
It's crazy you almost did that.
I mean that happens though.
There was one AKB48 member.
She quit when she graduated.
I don't know if she...
Opened the ramen place.
But she like started working at a ramen place.
Weird stuff.
You!
My friend really wishes to meet you at Afkai Expo but sold out instantly.
Sold out?
I thought it was a lottery.
I hope to see you there though at your panel.
I love you so much.
Can't wait for us to see you at Afkai.
Thank you!
Fantastic!
It is a lottery.
It was and then there was a sale of leftovers.
Who applied and then didn't want to come see me?
But it got taken up instantly.
I had no idea that there was going to be an open ticket sale.
Really?
Oh, I had no idea.
I thought it was only a lottery.
Pastel Sonico!
Sending love, man.
Thank you!
You're my favorite weirds, dude.
Thanks, Nexy.
What a crazy person that could have been us.
Yeah, that could have been me.
That could have been me.
You'll never guess who won it.
Oh gosh, I'm scared.
There was only one left?
What?
Actually, just one?
Someone had to cancel.
That's crazy.
That only...
The one piece.
That's insane that there was just like...
The one person canceled and then the one opened up.
That's so funny.
Oh my gosh.
Are you guys okay?
Trying to get the one?
I'm excited, though.
I'm so excited.
My first convention?
Oh my god.
Oh my gosh.
It's going to be a busy, busy, busy weekend, though.
You're a super...
Chu gotcha.
Sorry.
No win.
Sorry, David.
I just saw your thing.
Your don't know, too.
I haven't been here long, but as I see it, you have always been loved.
As an indie that's active for less than a year...
As an indie that's active for less than a year, you had more wiki entries than some much bigger VTubers.
Wiki, wiki, wiki, wiki entries.
So happy I became a member.
Here's to the future.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Wiki, wiki.
Wait.
Wiki entries.
Like a Wikipedia?
Like a... There's the VTuber wiki, though, right?
Thank you.
Thank you for whoever's updating that.
I suppose.
Probably hadn't been updated in a really long time.
Good luck reaching out to new people.
I know it can be hard sometimes, but I know you can do it.
Have a good night.
Thanks, Merlin!
Oh yeah, it's pretty late now, isn't it?
If you guys had the day off, maybe people in the United States, then I hope you had a good day off.
The feet wiki.
Shut up, Cole.
What are you at?
I saw the figure you made!
It looks so good!
But don't put it on the feet wiki, please!
It looks so awesome.
Thank you for making it.
CD?
Is that how you say your name?
Sedai.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
The crazy thing about the VTuber wiki is that anyone can edit it.
Even me?
I'm gonna go edit my own wiki.
I'm just gonna copy and paste the Metal Gear wiki.
I'm gonna copy and paste the synopsis of Metal Gear Solid.
I'm gonna replace by it.
Don't do that.
There's probably some people that would be so upset if you just erased all their hard work.
And then...
And then they're like...
They come back, they're just like...
Oh, something else happened with Mint Phantom.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna update her wiki.
And it's all gone.
And replaced by Metal Gear Synopsis.
Don't get banned.
Would I get banned for that?
It's my own wiki.
This is the information that people need to read.
Okay?
This is the information.
May I ask how is the stinkiest boy doing?
Thanks for asking, Sham.
Andrejko, thanks for the 10 gifted!
I forgot.
Wait, hold on.
I forgot if you mentioned this before, but do you accept snacks as gifts of Kai?
Sealed snacks...
I...
Probably.
I think it's technically said no food.
But I kind of...
I don't really mind.
I mean...
I don't know.
You can fill the page with all new mint lore.
But...
Um...
Butaro!
He...
He's been acting a little weird lately.
Um...
Lately he's been like just...
Very much like hanging out under the bed.
And I can't get him out.
Like he'll eat...
But he just doesn't hang out with me.
I think he is in this weird adjustment with...
Um...
With Paz.
And that like...
Paz started sleeping in the bed just a little bit.
And I think it's made him a little self-conscious or...
Not self-conscious.
A little...
Um...
Worried?
Like maybe it's like his...
His personal space is getting taken over.
So...
How old is he?
He's pretty old.
But he's still very active.
Like he's still running around.
Like they play together.
So...
But then he just kind of goes and retreats under the bed.
Yeah.
He's very territorial.
He's super duper territorial.
So...
Um...
Uh...
But...
He's sour about having an interloper.
Yeah.
Which is...
I thought it was weird because...
Um...
It's been over a month now.
But...
Um...
I think because...
It only...
He only started acting this way once she started sleeping in the bed with me.
So...
I think he was just like...
Whoa.
I'm fine with her being around.
But in the bed?
Um...
That is my spot.
I won't be able to harvest any in time for Afkai.
But I think...
If I can get some honey from my beehives...
Would she want some?
Technically, it's food and not sealed.
No judgment if not.
Oh, morning dew.
That sounds so awesome.
But honestly, I also worry about traveling with it.
Um...
And I'm afraid that maybe even staff would reject it.
So...
I don't know.
I'm so sorry.
I hope that sounds...
I would love your honey.
I want to get fresh honey.
I recently got a new cat.
And my old cat has been worried about giving her cuddles to make sure she remembers she's not being replaced.
Yeah.
I've been trying to do that a lot with him.
So I'm like...
I'm just like...
I give him lots of hugs and kisses.
So...
Hopefully, he knows that he's not being replaced.
Mm-hmm.
Okay.
So...
Um...
Okay, guys.
I think I'm gonna go...
I gotta get some more water.
So I think I'm gonna go head out.
Um...
I will...
I'm probably...
Okay.
So I'm gonna make a schedule for this week.
But I'm also gonna write like on it like...
Off Kai and then also for next week and the week after.
I'm basically gonna be gone three weeks now that I think about it.
Wait.
Not three weeks.
Two weeks.
But I will still be streaming.
So...
And then once I get back...
Once I get back from Japan...
Thank you!
Thanks to the five gifts and thank you!
You guys...
I was gonna ask for permission.
But...
I'm not asking.
When I get back...
Metal Gear Saturdays are back on the menu, baby!
Whippy!
Starting at Metal Gear Solid 1.
And we'll be playing Metal Gear up until...
Whenever I feel like stopping.
So...
Yippee!
Is Fortnite a snake count?
Oh my gosh!
I should play that, right?
I should...
I wonder if I could get Doki to play Fortnite with me.
I should ask her.
So...
We're finally getting acid!
Yeah!
So I did...
I know I did the twin snakes...
Some time ago...
But I really really just wanna have all of the Metal Gears kind of on my resume in my channel.
So...
I hope you guys don't mind...
That I'll be playing a lot of Metal Gear up until probably the end of the year.
Are we getting survive?
Oh, that's another thing I need to play with Doki.
There's too much stuff.
Eliezer, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hoping for Ace Combat 2.
I think once I'm done with the Metal Gear stuff, I will go into Ace Combat.
And then I think after Ace Combat, I might even start Xenoblade.
So, it is a long journey.
Time to put Doki into playing MGS.
But it will be like a long...
I feel like almost probably a year's worth of just like long story-based games.
You can, I guess, look forward to that.
Yippee!
And of course...
It's not just the only stuff that I'll be playing.
So, Memble, Fortnite maybe?
That'd be fun!
Wait, can we do like a lobby?
Or is it...
Would I have to...
Can I do a lobby or...
Monado time.
Yes, you can.
Is Ape Escape 3 a part of...
Metal Gear Solid Completionism?
Asking for a totally not monkey friend.
I want to do as much Metal Gear stuff as I can.
So, it is not off the table.
Hoping for a Minecraft adventure with Doki.
Maybe finding diamonds.
Again?
I don't think I've ever gone on a diamond...
thing.
But I will see.
We will see.
MangaCon!
Thanks for the 10 gifted.
Thank you.
But yeah, that's just kind of some of my future plans that I've been thinking about.
And...
Like I said, I know I've played Metal Gear before.
So, I hope that it will still be a fun experience for people.
I was kind of nervous.
Because I was like, what if people don't want to watch me play.
If I've already played everything before.
And I already know all the twists and I know this and that.
But...
Hopefully...
Like I said, I kind of just want...
The games on my channel.
So if people...
Come to my channel, they're just like...
Wow, she really likes Metal Gear.
You can always play MGS1 Integral English and VR missions.
Check them off your resume.
And then you can officially say you've played all versions of MGS1.
True!
One thing that I wanted to do...
Was...
Was play...
The different versions of the game.
So basically, like...
If I play the HD collection of something...
Maybe I'll play the original PS2 version of it.
This time.
So...
I'm still working on that.
To...
To give it a little bit of...
Difference.
Hey Bozo, do better...
Oh, do better...
What?
Oh sorry, I'll do better.
You better do whatever the hell you want.
I completely read it as do better.
Stop!
I'm gonna cry again with Peace Walker ending.
Me too!
Oh gosh.
I just...
I'm actually most excited to play MGS2 again.
Truly.
I think at the end I'm just gonna be a...
Little baby ball and just like...
I don't know.
There's something about the end of MGS2 that makes me feel so...
Even though it was right and so silly, dumb, stupid.
But yeah.
Anyway.
Do better, Mint.
Okay.
I'm gonna go to bed.
And um...
I'll see you guys tomorrow.
Don't know what I'm playing tomorrow.
Oh wait.
Maybe I think I do know...
Why don't...
Wait.
Uh...
I had an idea for something I was gonna do tomorrow and I don't remember.
So I'm gonna...
I'm gonna sleep on it.
No Mint not Metal Gear Survive is the...
I have to do it!
Just a little bit.
Any chance of uploading your truck rave performance to members to premiere on one of your off days?
I don't know.
For those of us who can't make it to Off-Kai.
Oh!
Um...
I can try.
Uh...
I...
Oh!
The one that I recorded.
I pre-recorded.
Um...
Yes.
Let me write that down so I can have it set up as a premiere for the weekend.
Um...
Upload...
Oh!
What just happened?
I jumped.
I did a...
I did a jump.
Um...
Upload...
Truck...
To members.
Hmm.
What was that?
I don't even know.
Okie dokie.
Thank you guys for hanging out with me!
Thank you guys for...
Um...
Spending your Monday with me!
If you haven't watched the podcast yet...
Uh...
You...
You can watch it while...
You know...
While both of us...
Mia and Matara...
Will be...
M-I-A...
A little bit this weekend.
And KFCF too!
Thanks for the vibe gift attack!
Thank you!
You have 8 remaining jumps down.
And um...
It was a nice podcast.
I'm glad...
I'm glad!
Thank you guys for listening!
Thank you!
And I'll see you guys tomorrow!
Same time!
Atsumita!
Oh!
You know what time it is...
Do do do...
Do do...
Let me tell you something...
Is there something weird...
Sleeping in your bed...
Ah Oh!
Let me tell you something...
Busting makes me feel good...
You like the sharp glasses...
Busting, busting, busting, busting...
Busting, busting, busting...
Bustin', bustin'!
Look like Sissle?
I know!
I realized I should have worn these during Ghost Trick.
Sleeping in your bed.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, invisible man!
Sleeping in your bed!
Oh!
Let me tell you something...
Please remember to...
Rubbing the wind to Matara on the next podcast.
You know it!
Freaky ghost maid!
Morning, dude!
Thank you!
Freaky man, baby!
Ow, ow, ow if you're all alone.
Let me sleep in your bed.
Let me tell you something.
Sleeping makes me feel good.
Freaky ghost diaper.
Where did you get the diaper from?
I ain't afraid of no sleep.
I ain't afraid of no bed.
An invisible bed.
Freaky ghost bed!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Mustang, mustang, mustang, mustang, mustang, mustang, mustang.
Signs!
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin' Makes me feel good.
Feel good, feel good.
Spitfire!
Thank you.
Full of the vibe.
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Mustang for all.
Busted.
Bustin' bustin'!
Busted!
Busted.
Thongs!
Thongs, thank you as well!
For that ten...
Wait, was it ten?
Wait, can I count?
What was it?
Wait, where did it go?
Oh!
Five!
Thank you for the five, Krypton!
Bye!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Bye-bye!